İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 7 Ekim 2024 Pazartesi günü 29. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Exception Handling konusuyla devam ediyorduk. Biraz daha konuşacağımız alt başlıklar var.
Ondan sonra jenerik programlama konusuna geçeceğiz.
Şimdi şöyle bir hatırlayalım nerede kaldığımızı.
No Accept Specifier'ı ve No Accept Operatör'ünü gördük.
İkisi farklı şeylerde aynı anahtar sözcük kullanılmasına rağmen.
Exception Garantilerinden bahsettik.
Bir fonksiyonun No Accept anahtar sözcüğüyle bildirilmesi fonksiyonun Exception Trove etmeyeceği garantisi anlamına geliyordu.
O konuda örnekler verdik.
Ve nereye kadar geldik sevgili arkadaşlar?
Exception göndermeme garantisi vermesine karşın yani No Fail garantisi vermemesine karşın Exception Trove ederse ne oluyor?
Yanıt Terminate fonksiyonu çağrılıyor.
Terminate fonksiyonunun çağrıldığı önemli senaryolardan biri de bu.
No Accept fonksiyonun Exception göndermesi.
Arkadaşlar bu da şu demek.
Bir fonksiyonu evet No Accept olarak işaretlemenin önemli faydaları var bugün de göreceğiz.
Ama eğer bu çiğnenirse İngilizcesiyle Violate edilirse bunun bedeli programınızın sonlanması.
Bu yanlışlıkla gözlem kaçırıldığı için yapılmış olabilir ya da bazı durumlarda özellikle fonksiyonunu No Accept olarak işaretleyip Exception göndermesi durumunda özellikle programın sonlandırılmasını istemiş olabilirsiniz.
Yani onun olmaması gerekiyor bu durumda ne kadar erken fail olursa o kadar iyi mantığıyla.
Şimdi önce bunu bir göstermek istiyorum.
Gerçekten bir fonksiyonu tanımlayalım ve bu fonksiyon No Accept olarak bildirilsin.
Fiylen bunu bir yaşayalım görelim.
Mesela full fonksiyonu No Accept olarak bildirilsin.
Fakat bar fonksiyonunu çağırsın.
Bu arada derleyici Compile Time'da hiçbir şekilde kontrol etme yükümlülüğüne sahip değil.
Zaten tipik olarak da kontrol etmez.
Zaten etme şansı da olamaz.
Çünkü fonksiyonun tanımını da görmüyor çoğu durumda değil mi?
Bar fonksiyonu da çağırıldığı zaman kodunda bir yerde runtime'da Exception True Etsy.
std.exe başlık dosyasında dair edelim.
Bugün standart kütüphanenin gönderdiği Exception'lardan da bahsedeceğiz.
Örneğin std.runtimeerör türünden hata göndersin.
Bu durumda full fonksiyonu çağrıldığında No Accept garantisi ne olacak?
Violate edilmiş olacak.
Yine Terminate'in çağrıldığını daha iyi gösterebilmek için
MyTerminate fonksiyonu var.
MyTerminateAlt.
Böyle daha iyi görme şansına sahip oluyoruz.
Bu da Abort fonksiyonunu çağırsın.
Evet şimdi main fonksiyonu içinde.
Önce setTerminate'i çağırayım.
Ondan sonra bir try blue'u oluşturayım.
Ve full'u çağırayım.
Buradaki Exception yakalanacak mı?
Hayır.
Programın akışı burada Bar fonksiyonu Exception Trove ettiğinde Terminate'in çağrılmasıyla sonlanacak.
Gördüğünüz gibi Terminate'i çağrıldım.
Arkadaşlar şimdi bazı fonksiyonlar doğası gereği ya da onlara duyulan güven gereği zaten No Accept yapılmak zorunda.
Fakat Destructor konusunda şöyle bir istisna var.
Bir sınıfın Destructor'ını No Fail garanti vermenize gerek yok.
Default olarak zaten No Accept garantisi veriyor.
Yani bakınız şimdi kodu biraz değiştirelim.
Bunu saklayalım.
Ve bu kez bir sınıf oluşturalım.
Class Natch
Public
Sınıfın Destructor'ı
Tildanage
Burada sanki No Accept anahtar sözcüğü varmış gibi.
Hatta bakınız.
Şöyle bir ifade yazalım.
No Accept
My Class
My Class değil, Natch de ismi.
Natch
Hilda
No Accept operator'ın operanda olan ifade
Unevaluated kontekste olduğu için
burada böyle bir ifade yazmamın bir zararı yok.
Çünkü Evaluate edilmiyor.
Unst Xperi
Auto
B
Eşittir
B'nin true olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Oysa burada No Accept anahtar sözcüğü yok.
Bu durumda
Diyelim ki
Destructor
Bir exception
Pro ederse ki asla etmemeli.
Daha doğrusu
Destructor
Exception
Pro ederse
Dışarı sızmamalı.
Yani şu kabul edilir.
Destructor
Exception
Pro eder
Ama yakalar.
Yani destructor
Normal şekilde sonlanır.
Ama programın akışı
Destructor'dan çıkmamalı.
Pro
Runtime Error
Error
From
Destructor
Buraya şöyle bir ifade yazalım.
Natch
Mine Edge
Mine Edge nesnesi için destructor çağrıldığında
Destructor
Exception
Pro edecek.
Destructor
Exception
Pro
Ettiğinde
Terminate
Fonksiyon
Çağrılacak.
Şimdi destructor
Neden
Exception
Pro
Etmemeli?
Arkadaşlar
Eğer
Aslında
Kural şu
Bir
Exception
Handle
Edildiğinde
Stack
Unwinding
Süreci
İçinde
Yine
Bir
Sınıfın
Herhangi bir kod
Exception
Pro
Ederse
Terminate
Çağrılıyor.
Eğer buna müsaade edilseydi zaten
Exception
Pro
Edildiğinde
Exception
Yakalandığında
Stack
Unwinding
Sırasında
Nesnelerin
Destructor'ı
Çağrılıyor ya
O zaman
Yine
Terminate
Fonksiyonu
Çağrılacaktı.
Resul
Muhammed
Adın sorusu
Buradan
Blade
Kılasını
Yazarken
Karşılaştım.
Constructor'ın
Object'i
Construct
Etmesini
Durdurmak
İçin
Exception
Pro
Etmek
İyi
Bir
Usul
Mü?
Olu
Geçen
Derste
Konuşmuştuk
Resul
Bir
Kez
Daha
Oraya
Değineyim.
Constructor'ın
Görevi
Sınıf
Nesnesini
Oluşturmak.
Sınıf
Nesnesini
Oluşturmak
Derken
Sınıf
Nesnesinin
Kullanılabilir
Bir
Durumda
Olması
İçin
Arkadaşlar
Ne
Olması
Gerekiyor?
İn
Varyantlarının
Tutması
Gerekiyor.
Constructor
Nesneyi
Doğru
Bir
Şekilde
Oluşturamayacaksa
O
Zaman
Exception
Pro
Etmesi
Zaten
Beklenen
Durum.
Yani
Sistemde
Exception
Pro
Etme
Konusunda
Bir
Kısıtlama
Yoksa
Zaten
Görevini
Yapamayan
Kullanılabilir
Bir
Nesne
Oluşturamayan
Constructor'lar
İçin
En Doğal
Davranış
Exception
Pro
Etmesi.
Şimdi
Buraya
Geri
Dönecek
Olursak
Destructor
Exception
Draw
Etmemeli
Zaten
No
Accept
Olarak
Bildiriliyor
Default
Olarak.
Yani
Bunu
Değiştirme
Şansınız
Yok.
Ama
Bunun
Dışında
Move
Constructor'ın
Buraya
Dikkat
Özellikle
No
Accept
Olması
Gerekiyor.
Ama
Move
Constructor
Ya da
Move
Assignment
Default
Olarak
No
Accept
Değil.
Yani
Move
Constructor'ınızın
No
Accept
Olmasından
Siz
Sorumlusunuz
Bir
Sınıfın
Move
Constructor'ının
No
Accept
Olmasından
Nedeni
Ve
No
Accept
Olmasının
Faydalarına
Ayrıca
Bakacağız.
Yine
Aynı
Şekilde
Move
Assignment'dan
Beklenen
Tipik
Olarak
No
Accept
Olması
Swap
Fonksiyonlarının
Kesinlikle
No
Accept
Olması
Gerekiyor.
Ve
Default
Olarak
No
Accept
Değiller.
Başta
Standart
Kütüphanenin
Swap
Fonksiyonu
Olmak
Sıra
Bütün
Swap
Fonksiyonlarının
No
Accept
Olması
Öngörülüyor.
Memory
Deallocation
Fonksiyonlarının
Yine
No
Accept
Olması
Gerekiyor.
Yani
Bunların
No
Accept
Olmaması
Daha
Sıradışı
Bir
Durum.
Onu
Özellikle
Söyleyelim.
Şimdi
No
Accept
Specifier
İle
İlgili
Bir
İki
Noktaya
Daha
Değinmemiz
Gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar
Bir
Function
Overriding
İki
Function
Pointers
Özellikle
Function
Pointers
C++
İlave
Kurallara
Sahip
Oldu.
Ama
Önce
Function
Overriding
Bahsedelim.
Yani
Virtual
Dispatch
Mekanizmasından.
Her C++
Programcısının
Hatta
Her
Programcının
İlk
Blok
Yazısı
Herhalde
Solid
İlkeleri.
Yani
Şöyle
Solid
İlkeleri
diye
Arama
Yapın.
Binlerce
İyi
Kötü
Blok
Yazısı
Bulursunuz.
Makale
Ben
Solid
İlkelerinin
Abartıldığı
Yönünde
Bir
Görüş
Eserim.
Yani
Önemsiz
Demiyorum
Ama
Biraz
Abartılmış.
Zaten
Son
Derece
Doğal.
Herkesin
Yaptığı
Bildiği
Şeyler
Çoğunlukla
Solid
Akroniminin
Nereden
Geldiğini
Biliyorsunuz.
Nereden
Geliyor?
Yani
Uydurma
Bir
Akronim.
Aslında
Solid
Sözcüğünün
Her
Harfi
İlkelerden
Birini
Temsil
Ediyor.
Öyle
Değil mi?
İşte
Efendim
Single
Responsibility
Principle
Open
Closed
Principle
Vesaire.
Ama
Buradaki
L'ye
Deyinmek
İstiyorum.
L'nin
Ne
Olduğunu
Hatırlayan
Var
Mı?
Solid
Deki
L'nin
L'in
Substitutional
Principle
L'in
Bir
Bilim
İnsanı
Hanımefendi
Barbara
L'in
Buradaki
Prankiz'in
Bildiği
Bir
Şey
Gibi
Görünüyor
Ama
Çok
Da
Dikkat
Evilmeye
Biliyor
Aslında
Solid'in
L'in
Çok güzel bir söz gerçekten. Konuyu bence daha iyi açıklıyor.
Bu kimin için söylenmiş bir söz, cümle? Türemiş sınıflar için.
For derived classes. Yani şunu kastediyor.
Türemiş sınıflar, taban sınıfın client'larından talep ettiğinden daha fazla talepte bulunmayacaklar.
Ve taban sınıfın, biraz eski bir söz olacak ama, vaatlerinden daha azını da vaat etmeyecekler.
Bu son derece basit. Neden?
Şimdi bizim polimorfik bir sınıf hiyerarşimiz olsa, tipik olarak polimorfik kodlar taban sınıf pointerına ya da referansına bağlı olarak yazılıyor değil mi?
Yani o kodlar, taban sınıfın taleplerine ve vaatlerine dikkate alıyor.
Eğer türemiş sınıflardan biri ya da birden fazlası taban sınıfın yetindiği koşullarla yetinmezse, client'larından daha fazla şey talep ederse, o sağlanmayacak.
Çünkü burada interfej taban sınıfa göre oluşturuluyor.
Yine taban sınıfın verdiği bazı garantiler varsa, ben o polimorfik kodu kullanan kod olarak ya da onu yazan programcı olarak taban sınıfın garantilerine güveneceğim.
Ama ya orada örneğin virtual dispatch'te çağrılan bir fonksiyon, havan sınıfın sanal fonksiyonunun interfejsteki efendim garantilerini sağlamıyorsa, o zaman orada bir problem olacak.
İşte bu overriding mekanizmasında, virtual dispatch mekanizmasında no except olması bir fonksiyonun, hemen bir örnek verelim.
public, örneğin virtual, void, ne olsun, full, no except.
E şimdi bakın, havan sınıf diyor ki, benim diyor full fonksiyonum çağrıldığında bir exception gönderilmeyecek.
Bu durumda türemiş sınıfların overriding'ın da buna uyması gerekiyor değil mi?
Yani örneğin şöyle bir sınıf olsaydı, class der, arkadaşlar, public base, bu fonksiyonu overriding etseydi.
Public, virtual, void, full, override.
Şimdi full'un overriding'ı bu garantiyi veriyor mu?
Cevap hayır.
Çünkü no except'ten atar sözcüğü yok.
Tabii.
Derlediğim zaman syntax hatası olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Bu dilin kuralı.
Derleyicinin verdiği syntax hatası mesajına bakalım.
Diyor ki,
Overriding virtual function has less restrictive exception specification than base class virtual member.
Virtual function.
Ama tam da dediğim ilkeyi çok güzel gösteriyor aslında.
Hani risk of substitutional principle'a bence verilmesi gereken örneklerden, güzel örneklerden biri.
Ben full'ya güvenip, bu fonksiyonun exception throw etmediğine güvenerek bir kod yazsam,
orada o fonksiyona der sınıfı türünden bir nesne gelse,
onun full fonksiyonu çağrılsa, bu exception throw edebilir demek.
Bakın tersi olsaydı,
bunda bir sorun yok.
Bunda bir sorun var mı?
Bunda bir sorun yok.
Çünkü türemiş sınıfın,
arkadaşlar,
full fonksiyonu,
türemiş sınıfın full fonksiyonu,
evet diyor ki,
ben exception throw etmeyeceğim.
Ama tavan sınıfın böyle bir sözü yok.
Yani daha fazla garanti veriyor.
Garantiyi kısıtlamıyor.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
O zaman şöyle bir tekrar edersek,
tavan sınıfın bir sanal fonksiyonu,
a virtual function of a base class,
eğer no except olarak bildirilmişse,
ona override eden fonksiyonların da
no except olarak bildirilmesi gerekiyor.
C++ standartlarıyla da bazı şeyler değişti.
Mesela bakın bir örnek vereyim.
class,
my exception ya da date exception,
public,
stud exception,
benimki date sınıfı ödevinde.
Bu arada arkadaşlar,
iki tane ödev var bence önemli.
Biri taş makası oyunu,
biri date sınıfı.
Daha önce de söylemiştim ama
henüz randevu alan randevu mu demek gerekiyor?
iki kişi oldu.
Onun dışında kimse
kod revue için başvurmadı.
Ama herhangi bir zamanda,
kursun sonuna kadar
talepte bulunabilirsiniz.
Yani ödevlere yazılı olarak cevap vermek yerine
birlikte kod revue yapmak,
hem sohbet etmiş oluyoruz,
hem de sorulara cevap verebiliyorum.
Bazen arkadaşım ödev yapan benimle
aynı görüşte olmaya da biliyor.
Bazı şeyler çünkü sürekli bir onları da konuşuyoruz.
Çalışverişleri de buluyoruz.
Evet.
Şimdi bakınız.
Ooo.
Süper.
Hayırlı olsun şimdiden Resul.
Ne zaman olursa önemli değil.
Arkadaşlar bakın.
Mesela
Avance sınıfın,
Exceptions sınıfının
VAT fonksiyonu
aslında NoExcept.
C++'ın tam ne zaman NoExcept oldu
bilmiyorum ama
dolayısıyla
üremiş sınıf şimdi
VAT fonksiyonunu
override ettiğinde
derli işler çoğunlukla bunu görmezden geliyorlar.
Ama bazı derli işler
sentaks hatası olarak belirliyor.
Siz de deneyin.
Bakınız.
const char yıldız
what
const
efendim
override
normalde şimdi dilin kurallarına göre
bunun sentaks hatası olması gerekiyor.
Ama çoğunlukla benim gördüğüm
bazı derli işler de oradan
diagnostik veriyor.
Mesela
Visual Studio Microsoft derli işleri
diagnostik vermiyor.
aynı nedenle
çünkü
bu türemiş sınıf
taban sınıfın sanal fonksiyonu
NoExcept olduğu için
bunun da NoExcept olması lazım.
Bir örnek vermek istedim.
gelelim ikinci noktaya
fonksiyon pointerları
arkadaşlar
function pointers
fonksiyon pointerlarında
daha önce
NoExcept anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanma diye bir şey yoktu
modern C++'dan önce.
Yani bakınız
şimdi int
yıldız
fp1
int
bu bir fonksiyon göstericisi
bu da bir fonksiyon göstericisi
fp2
bu iki fonksiyon göstericisinin
aslında bildirimlerinde
bir farklılık var.
fp1 diyor ki
ey diyor
beni kullanan kod
benim gösterdiğim fonksiyonu
benim vasılamla çağırabilirsin
ama
böyle bir çağrı
exception throw edebilir.
ama fp2 diyor ki
benimle de bir fonksiyon çağrısı
yapabilirsin
ama
benim vasılamda
yapacağım fonksiyon çağrısı
exception throw etmeme garantisi veriyor
diyor.
Şimdi bu durumda
siz
burayı çok dikkatli izlemeye çalışın
örneğin
int
bar int
no except
Şimdi bakınız
eğer
pp2 gibi bir fonksiyon göstericisine
bu gibi bir fonksiyonun
adresiyle
ilk değer verirseniz
ya da atama yaparsanız
yine
aslında
kullanıcı kodu
riske etmiş olursunuz
değil mi?
hem fp2
benimle yapılan çağrılar
exception throw etmeyecek
diyor
fakat
tutacağı adres
exception throw edebilen
bir fonksiyonun adresi
dolayısıyla
sentaks olarak
bu
yasaklanmış durumda
bu sentaks hatası
yani
bu şekilde bildirilen bir fonksiyona
no except garantisi olan
bir fonksiyonun
ancak adresini
atayabilirsiniz
ya da ilk değer olarak
verebilirsiniz
olsam birazdan
sorunuza cevap vereceğim
bunun imza ile bir ilişkisi var mı?
var
evet
yani bu
imzanın bir parçası
ama bir kısıtlamayla
önce burayı anlayalım
barın adresini
atasaydım
barın adresiyle
initialize etseydim
bir sorun olmayacaktı
ama bakın
tersine
eğer şöyle olsaydı
bu
exception
throw etmeme garantisi
vermiyor
fp ile yapılan
çağrılar
dolayısıyla
buna
barın adresiyle
ilk değer vermek
ya da barın adresini
atamak
bu sentaks hatası değil
genel mantığı anlamamız
çok önemli
yani şu anda
herhangi bir garantiyi
daraltmış
olmuyorum
fp
arkadaşlar ben
exception
throw edebilirim
diyor ama
exception
throw etmeme garantisi
veren bir fonksiyonu
gösterebilir
ama exception
throw etmeme garantisi
veren
bir
fonksiyon
göstericisi
exception
throw etme
ihtimali olan
bir fonksiyonun
adresini
tutamaz
dolayısıyla
fp'ye
barın adresini
atamak
ya da fp'ye
bu'nun adresini
atamak
bir sentaks hatası
değil
her ikisi de
geçerli
şimdi
Olsan Bey'in
sorusuna gelecek olursak
bu durumda
no except
olup olmaması
fonksiyon göstericisinin
ya da fonksiyonun
doğrudan
interfeste ilgili
bir ayrım
sağladığına göre
bu açıdan baktığımızda
no except
imzanın
bir parçası
ama
C++
standartı
diyor ki
imzanın
bir parçası
ama
overloading de
kullanılamaz
yani şöyle bir şey
olamaz
örneğin
iki tane
full fonksiyonu
bildireyim
biri
no except
olan full fonksiyonu
öbürü
no except
olması dışında
imzada ve
geri dönüş
değeri türünde
bir farklılık
olmasın
no except
garantisi
vermeyen
bir fonksiyon
bu function
overloading
değil
bu doğrudan
syntax hatası
anlaşıldı
bildirimler
arasında
çelişkinli
olması
syntax hatası
yani
sorunuzun tam cevabı
bence şöyle olmalı
imzanın
bir parçası
ama
overloading
amaçlı
kullanılamıyor
takip edebildik mi
arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar bakın
bakın şimdi
benim
en sevdiğim
C++ yazarı
ve konuşmacılarından
biri daha önce de
söylemiş olmalıyım
Nikolai Yostis
çok sayıda kitabı var
biliyorsunuz
bu
STL kitabını
zaten referans
olarak vermiştim
Mu Semantics
isimli bir kitabı var
C++ 20
standartına
ilişkin bir kitabı var
gerçekten
kitapları
diğerlerine göre
çok daha
kapsamlı
ve
konuya da
çok hakim bir
arkadaş
konuşmaları da
çok çok güzel
C++ standart komitesine
muhalif bazı durumlarda
arkadaşlar
özellikle
Ranges kütüphanesine
C++ 20
standartıyla gelen
çok
ne diyelim
radikal bir şekilde
eleştiriyor
yanlış tasarlandığı
konusunda
neyse efendim
neden şimdi
Nikolai Yostis'ten
bahsettim
Alman bu arada
Alman olduğu için
bir şeyle yazıyor
ben
Yostis diye okuyorum
çünkü
çok güzel bir örnek
vermiş
Nikolai Yostis
kitabında
bu
No Accept
garantisiyle ilgili
onu ben doğrudan
alıntılayacağım
buraya
kitaba da koydum
alıntı olduğunu
göstererek
arkadaşlar bakın
şimdi
biraz anlaşılması
zor olabilir ama
çok güzel bir örnek
şimdi
taban sınıfa bakalım
B sınıfına
buradaki
No Accept
Geçen dersimizde
görmüştük
No Accept
Specifier'ından
sonra bir parantez
içinde
bir Constant
Expression'ın
olması
bu Constant
Expression
True
değer üretiyorsa
Compile Time'da
No Accept
garantisi
verdiği anlamına
geliyor değil mi
buraya kadar
tamam mı
peki
Bayes'in
sanal fonksiyonu
olan
Funk'ın
No Accept
garantisi
verme koşulu
ne
diyor ki
Size of Int
8'den
küçükse
ben diyor
No Fail
garantisi
veriyorum
oysa
Bayes sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
Derived
sınıfı
o da
No Accept
anahtar
sözcüğüyle
bildirilmiş
ama
onun
koşulu
Size of Int'in
4'den
küçük olması
yani
bu durumda
şöyle bir
senaryo
düşünelim
Size of Int'in
örneğin
arkadaşlar
4'den
küçük olması
gerekiyor
ama
4 olması
durumunda
avans sınıfın
No Accept
garantisine
uyuyor
ama
türemiş sınıfın
No Accept
garantisine
uymuyor
burayı anladık mı
bu durumda
türemiş sınıfın
override'ı
avans sınıfın
verdiği garantiden
daha azını
vermiş oluyor
dolayısıyla
bunun
yine
Sentax hatası
olması gerekiyor
bakın
derlediğim zaman
derleyicim
açık açık
okuyalım
yine aynı
hata mesajını
verdi
Overriding
Virtual Function
has
less
Restrictive
Exception
Specification
than
Base Class
Virtual Member
Function
Void Base
Func
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi
generic
programlama
tarafında
arkadaşlar
bu
No Accept
garantisi
verip
vermediğini
sınamaya
yarayan
çok sayıda
Meta Function
var
bunları
şimdi
anlatmayacağım
çünkü
generic
programlamayla
ilgili
temel
bilgilere
sahip
olmamız
gerekiyor
ama
en azından
görselleştirmek
için
bir
gönderme
yapalım
bence
generic
programlama
tarafında
en önemli
başlık
dosyalarından
biri
standart
kütüphanemizin
Type
Trades
başlık
dosyası
inşallah
bir aksilik
olmazsa
ilerleyen
haftalarda
ayrıntılı
olarak
göreceğiz
burada
çok sayıda
Meta Function
var
bu arada
Meta Function
terimini
açıklamadan
kullandım
kusuruma
bakmayın
arkadaşlar
Compile Time'da
hesaplama
yapan
o hesaplanan
bir değer
olabilir
value
ya da
efendim
hesaplanan
bir tür
olabilir
yapılara
Meta Function
deniyor
yani
Meta Function
terimindeki
Function
bildiğimiz Function
anlamında
değil
Meta Function'lar
zaten çok büyük
çoğunlukla
sınıf
olarak
temsil ediliyorlar
mesela
izleyin
birkaç tane
örnek vereyim
arkadaşlar
using
namespace
direktifini
kullanıyorum
mesela bakın
is
noter of
buradan da
seçmek daha zor
default
constructible
buna bir
tür
veriyorum
telkit argümanı
olarak
örneğin
class
my class
is noter of
default
constructible
my class
benim
kabirimle
açılımının
specialization
'ının
arkadaşlar
values'u
bir
boolean
değer
compile time'de
hesaplanan
eğer bu
true'ysa
bu şu anlama
geliyor
my class
sınıfının
default
constructor'ı
no
except
yani
exception
göndermeme
garantisi var
zaten
bakınız
bu şekilde
de sınayabiliriz
constexpr
auto
b
bütün sınamalar
compile time'de
yapılıyor
b'nin
true olduğunu
görüyoruz
en son
derste
sınıfın
special
member
function'larının
no
except
garantisi
verip
vermemesiyle
ilgili
kuralları
anlatmıştım
b'ye
görüyorsunuz
şu anda
true
ama örneğin
şöyle olsaydı
public
my class
user declared
olsaydı
şimdi
no except
olması için
specifier'ını
benim kullanmam
gerekecekti
dolayısıyla
no except
değil
bakın compile time'da
no except
olmadığını
anlayabiliyorum
tabi şimdi
generic programlama
tarafına
çokça girmek
istemiyorum
ama
böyle yazmak
yerine
daha kısa
şöyle
yazabiliyoruz
aynı şey
yani
type
trades
başlık
dosyasında
arkadaşlar
bunu
sınama
şansım
var
mesela
yine
generic
programlamaya
girmeyeyim
desem de
girmek
zorunda
kalıyorum
özellikle
no except
operatörünün
kullanımının
da çoğu
burayla ilgili
mesela
bakınız
diyelim ki
burada bir
fonksiyon
var
bir fonksiyon
çablonu
bu fonksiyonun
no except
garantisi
verip
vermediğini
örneğin
t türünün
bazı özellikleriyle
ilişkilendirebilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
örneğin
no except
buraya
eyle ilgili
bir
compile time
ifadesi yazsam
arkadaşlar
mesela
stut
is
type
trace
halen
diyelim ki
notro
copy
constructible
underscore
ve
e
şimdi
bu ne
anlama
gelecek
en azından
biraz
sezebilirsiniz
bu fonksiyonun
kendisi
değil
derleyicinin
fonksiyon
kodu
yazması
için
kullanacağı
bir
arkadaşlar
code
var mı
diyor ki
bu fonksiyon
eğer
t türünün
copy
constructörü
exception
true
etmeme
garantisi
veriyorsa
buradaki
compare time
ifadesi
true
değeri
sahip
olacak
o zaman
bu fonksiyonda
no except
olacak
mesela
class
by class
arkadaşlar
şöyle yapalım
default
constructible
alalım
daha kolay
görebilmek
için
fonksiyonu
bu şekilde
bildirelim
no except
punk
my class
soru
argüman
my class
bu durumda
derleyicinin
yazacağı
fonksiyonun
parametresi
my class
türünleri
olacak
ona
template
argümanı
deniyor
bu durumda
bu fonksiyonun
no except
garantisi
vermesi
my class
sınıfının
default
constructörünün
no except
garantisine
bağlanmış
olacak
peki bizim
my class
sınıfımızın
default
constructörü
no except
mi
önce bu
soruya cevap
verin
cevap
evet
o zaman
bu ifadenin
de
true olması
gerekir
constex
br
auto
b
no except
operatörünü
hatırlayalım
bakınız
true olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
bu arada
böyle bir özellik
de var
onu da
araya
sokalım
geçen derste
söylememiştim
şimdi
diyelim ki
siz
bir sınıfın
constructörünü
default
ediyorsunuz
my class
yani
special member
functionlarından
birini
default
ediyorsunuz
const
my class
red
eşittir
default
yani
takip edin
mesela bu sınıfın
şöyle bir veri elemanı
olsaydı
private
vektör başlık
dosyasını
dahil edelim
spot
vektörün
int açılımı
şimdi
copy
constructörün
no except
olup
olmadığına
bakalım
bunu
compile time'da
anlamak için
is
not
row
copy
constructible
underscore
ve
min
my class
açılımı
oradan
büyük ihtimalle
gösterecektir
bakın
false olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
compile time'da
ama
şunu da
yapma hakkınız
var
tabi yapma hakkınız
bunu yapmanızın
her zaman
iyi olacağı
anlamına
gelmiyor
derleyici
sen yine
default et
ama no except
olarak
default et
diyebiliyorsunuz
yani şimdi
derleyiciye
kalsa
benim kurallarına
göre
arkadaşlar
derleyicinin
yazdığı
copy
constructor
exception
throw
etme
ihtimali
olduğu için
no except
değil
ama şöyle
diyebiliyorsunuz
ben hem
derleyicinin
bu fonksiyonu
default etmesini
istiyorum
fakat aynı zamanda
no except
garantisi
istiyorum
bu durumda
eğer yardımcı
aracı
iyi implemente
etmişlerse
arkadaşlar
throw
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
my class'ın
belirli bir
fonksiyonu
için bu
sorgulamayı
nasıl yapabiliriz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
type trace
kütüphanesinde
special member
fonksiyonlar için
meta fonksiyonlar
var
ama
sınıfın
herhangi bir
üye fonksiyonu
için böyle bir
meta fonksiyon
yok
zaten şöyle
görebilirsiniz
birlikte bakalım
hepsi aynı
isimle
başlıyor
stud
is
notro
bakın
tek tek
bakalım
assignable
efendim
constructible
convertible
yani bir türden
bir türe
dönüşürken
exception
throw
etmeme
garantisi
copy
assignable
constructible
default
destructible
invocable
şunu
kullanabilirsiniz
is
notro
invocable
bakalım
isterseniz
is
notro
ya da
no
accept
operatörünü
kullanabilirsiniz
is
notro
invocable
cengizhan
cpp
reference
dot com
bakabilirsiniz
birinci parametresi
template parametresi
callable
diğerleri de
argüman
olan türler
bu
compile time'da
exception
throw
etme
ihtimali
olup
olmadığında
bu yolda
sınıyabilirsiniz
herhangi bir fonksiyon için
yani bunun dışında
doğrudan başka bir yol yok
fonksiyon ismiyle ilgili
bir fonksiyonun
çağrısının
exception
garantisi verip
vermediğini
böyle kontrol edebilirsiniz
ya da
no accept
operatörünü
ilgili
kontekste
kullanabiliyorsanız
kullanabilirsiniz
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şu
move
constructor'ın
exception
throw
etmeme
garantisinin
ne kadar önemli
olduğunu
bir örnekle
göstereceğim
ama
örnek bayağı
kapsamlı olduğu için
biraz da
zamanı oynamamız
gerekiyor
çünkü
kodun tamamını
ben burada
yazarsam
herhalde
yazması
üstünde
konuşması
15-20
dakikamızı
alabilir
o yüzden
yazdığım örneği
buraya
kopyalamayı
tercih ediyorum
kusuruma
bakmazsanız
ama açıklayacağız
birlikte
şimdi bakalım
arkadaşlar
string başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
krono başlık dosyasını
vektör başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
eksik bir şey kaldı mı
iostream başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
şimdi bu
örnek bence çok önemli
hani derler ya
usluk açıcı bir örnek
o yüzden
anlamanızda
son derece
fayda var
arkadaşlar
önce bu
ne sınıfına bakalım
ne ciz
any class
problem domeninde
bir karşılık aramayın
ne için
stu string türünden
bir nesi var
elemanı var
ne için
konstruktörü
baştan
şu uyarı yaptım
böyle bir sınıf
saçma değil mi
ne işe yarar
sorularını
sormamanız için
çünkü
konuyu anlatmaya yönelik
bir örnek
sınıfın ne iş yaptığı
neden böyle bir
konstruktörün
olduğu gibi sorulara
cevap veremeyecek
durumdayım
tabii ki
çünkü
böyle bir sınıf
yazmaz kimse
ama bakınız
necim konstruktörü
ne yapıyor
cevap
string sınıfının
fill parametre
dediğim
benim tabirimle
konstruktörüne
çağrı yaparak
ms isimli
data member'ı
initialize ediyor
neyle initialize ediyor
2000 tane
a karakteri
neden böyle bir
konstruktör yazdığımı
tahmin edebiliyor musunuz
çünkü
2000 tane
a karakterini
tutan
bir stringin
kopyalanmasıyla
taşınması
arasında ciddi
bir maliyet farkı
olur değil mi
Cengiz Han
Alihan
orayı anladık mı
yani neden böyle bir
konstruktör kullandığımı
örnekle ilişkisini
baştan sezmeyebilirsiniz
o yüzden
söyledim
2000 karakterlik
bir yazıyı
bir yerden bir yere
bir stringi
kopyalamakla
taşımak
ciddi maliyet farkı
taşırsanız
sadece
pointerlar
kopya edilecek
öyle değil mi
ama kopyalarsanız
yeni bir dinamik
bellek
allocation
olacak
yeni
allocate edilen
bellek bloğuna
diğer bellek
bloğundaki
2000 tane
a karakteri
kopyalanacak
bu sınıfın
copy
konstruktörü
arkadaşlar
yazılması
gerektiği gibi
yazılmış
size göstermek için
ben yazdım
artmışlar
bu da
sınıfın
move
konstruktörü
bana şunu
diyebilirsiniz
necati bunları yazmana
gerek var mıydı
zaten derleyici
bu şekilde
yazmıyor mu
yazıyor
ama
bir şeyi
görmenizi
istedim
şimdi
bakınız
burada
copy
konstruktörü
move
no
except
olması
gerektiği
gibi
burada ise
move
konstruktörü
no
except
değil
ipin ucunu
kaçırmayın
diye
biraz
bekleyeyim
en azından
bir arkadaşın
buraya kadar
anladığını
ifade
ederse
evet
move
konstruktörü
yapması
gerekeni
yapıyor
zaten
derleyiciye
de yazdırsaydık
derleyicinin
yazdığı move
konstruktörün
kodu böyle
olacaktı
değil mi
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
şimdi
bakınız
yine
kodda
bilmediğiniz
bazı
öğeleri
kullanıyorum
onu da
pusuna
bakmayın
ama
açıklayacağım
arkadaşlar
bir
vektör
konteynerında
dinamik
dizi
konteynerında
yüz bin
tane
neç
nesnesi
tutuyorum
burada
bu kod
çalıştığında
neç
sınıfının
default
konstruktörü
yüz bin
kez
çalışacağım
her
öğe
iç
böylece
mutlu
rasul
meriç
vektörde
yüz bin
tane
string
tutuluyor
olacak
ve vektörde
tutulan
yüz bin
tane
stringin
her biri
iki bin
tane
a karakterinde
tutan
yazı
olacak
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
fakat
burada
resize
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
kapasitesine
bir
arttırıyorum
söyleyin
bakalım
şimdi
vektörün
kapasitesi
artınca
ne oluyor
string sınıfında
da aynı şey
geçerliydi
tahmin etmeniz
zor
değil
reallocation
olacak
değil mi
yani
bravo
cengiz
yani
vektörün
tuttuğu
stringler
bir başka
bellek alanına
taşınacak
şimdi
bakın
peki
o
bellek alanına
taşınırken
eski
bellek alanındaki
stringler
yeni
bellek alanına
taşınırken
daha iyisi
daha pratiği
daha düşük
maliyetlisi
oradan oraya
taşımada
mu
construct
etmek
değil mi
kesinlikle
çünkü arada
çok ciddi
bir fark
var
ama
mu
construct
etmesi
için
daha sonra
yine konuşacağımız
nedenlerden
arkadaşlar
mu
construct
'ın
no
accept
garantisi
vermesi
gerekiyor
şimdi
no
accept
garantisinin
ne kadar
önemli
olduğunu
gösteren
bir örnek
şimdi
bakalım
bizim
mu
construct
'larımız
no
accept
garantisi
vermediği
için
vereni
yorum
satırına
aldım
bu durumda
eski bellek alanındaki
öğeler
yeni bellek alanına
copy
construct
yoluyla
arkadaşlar
aktarılacak
yani copy
construct
edilecek
buradaki
kodu
tahmin ediyorsunuz
bilenlerde
vardır
ama ben
henüz size
krono
kütüphanesini
anlatmadım
süreyi
ölçüyoruz
pekala
burada
iyi kötü
bir C
kodu da
yazabilirdik
yani
C'deki
C'nin
standart
fonksiyonundaki
clock
fonksiyonunu
da
çağırabilirdik
ama
o
saniye
olarak
verecekti
biz şimdi
milisaniye
olarak
şu
resize
işleminin
kaç
milisaniye
sürdüğünü
arkadaşlar
ne yapacağız
sınamış
olacağız
değerliyorum
166.987
milisaniye
şimdi
kodu
değiştirdim
tek değişiklik
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
ne yapmak
no accept
yapmak
aradaki
muazzam
farkı
gördük mü
anlaşıldı mı
evet
aslında
bakın çok güzel
başka bir örnek
bunu da
kopyalayacağım
izleyin
bunu da ben yazdım
şimdi
sentence diye bir sınıf var
hikaye tamamen aynı
o yüzden
tekrar etmiyorum
sentence sınıfının
mu
konstruktörü
a
no accept
b
değil
önce
no accept
olmasın
ve
yazdığım
main
fonksiyonuna
bakın
vektörün
sentence
açılımı
yani 3 tane
sentence tutan
sentence
buradaki sınıfın
ismi
vektör
buraya da güzel güzel
latince sözler yazdım
latinceyi seven var mı
meraklı olan var mı
vektörün
size'ını ve kapasitesini
yazdırdım
arkadaşlar
buraya kadar bir
derleyelim
evet bakın
3 kez
copy
konstruktör çağrıldı
size'ı 3
kapasitesi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şimdi
şuraya kadar olan
koç çalıştı
evet
şimdi bakın
resize fonksiyonuyla
yine kapasiteyi
bir arttırdım
ve
pushback
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
pushback fonksiyonunu
başta çağırmıyor
evet
bakın şimdi
bu
resize'ı çağırdığım için
takip edebiliyor muyuz
eski bellek bloğundaki
öğeler
yeni bellek bloğuna
kopyalanırken
demik örnekte
süreyle göstermiştim
ama şimdi
aslında
sentence sınıfının
copy
konstruktörü da var
move
fakat
move konstruktörü
no except olmadığı için
eski bellek alanındaki
öğeleri yeni bellek alanına
arkadaşlar
taşırken
move konstruktörü değil
copy konstruktörü
kullanıyor
görüyorsunuz
copy konstruktör
oysa
şimdi
move konstruktörü
no except yapalım
durumun değiştiğini göreceksiniz
görüyorsunuz değil mi
daha önceki
çalıştırmada
burada
üç kez
copy konstruktörü
çağrılmıştı
şimdi
üç kez
move konstruktörü
çağrıldı
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
optimizasyon
sözcüğü
çok geniş
anlam alanı
olan bir sözcük
şimdi optimizasyon
derken
bazen
kişiler diyor ki
optimization
neyin
optimizasyonundan
bahsediyorsun
şimdi
c++
kullanılan
ortamlarda
optimizasyon
derken
nelerden
bahsediliyor
olabilir
onlara biraz
değinmek istiyorum
biraz konu dışı
konunun dışına sapacağım
sonra konuyla
ilişkisini söyleyeceğim
arkadaşlar bir kere
tamamen
programlama
dilinden
bağımsız
işlemci tarafında
yapılan
optimizasyonlar
var
yani bunun
sizin yazdığınız
kodda
doğrudan bir ilgisi yok
işte
prefetching
branch
prediction
vs.
bunlar
işlemci tarafında
yapılan
optimizasyonlar
yani bunların
derleyicinin
yaptığı
optimizasyonla
bir alakası yok
bunu bir kere
ayıralım
o konular da
çok önemli
ama bu kursun
kapsamında
değil
işte
prefetching
belki
multi trading
konusuna
girdiğimizde
orada ister istemez
prefetchingden
biraz bahsetmemiz
gerekebilecek
ama
doğrudan
bu multi trading
söz konusu
değilse
o konuyu
bilmememizin
c++ tarafıyla
doğrudan
dil tarafıyla
bir alakası yok
onun dışında
derleyicinin
yaptığı
optimizasyon var
kod optimizasyonu
şu anlamda
onu artık
milyonlarca kez
abartıyorum
tabi
c'de de
c++'da
konuştuk
measure
as if
rule
yani
programın
gözlenebilir
davranışında
bir değişiklik
olmaması
kaydıyla
derleyici
yazdığınız kodu
farklı şekilde
yazılmış gibi
ele alabilir
nasılsa
gözlenebilir
davranış
değişmiyor
derleyici
burada kullandığı
onlarca
optimizasyon
tekniği var
ama
bir de şöyle bir
optimizasyon var
bunun şimdi farkına varmamış
olabilirsiniz
aslında
arkadaşlar
derleyicinin
kod seçimindeki
jenerik kodlarda
derleyicinin
kod seçimi
mesela az önceki
aslında ona bir örnek
az önce
ne oldu da
örneğin
derleyici
daha
etkin olsun
diye
copy
konstruktörü
değil
move
konstruktörü
çağırdı
yani
bunu neye göre
seçti
aslında
bu doğrudan
bildiğimiz anlamda
bir optimizasyon
değil değil mi
derleyici
compile time'da
koda bakarak
o kodumu
seçeyim
bu kodumu
bu kararı veriyor
bu ayrı bir
optimizasyon
kategorisi
yani derleyicinin
jenerik kodda
hangi kodu
seçeceğine
karar vermesi
genelde bu
optimizasyon
belki buna
demek de pek
doğru olmayabilir
ben optimizasyon
terimini kullanıyorum
ama bu ayrı bir
kategori değil mi
derleyicinin yaptığı
o kod optimizasyonunun
haricinde
bir de
jenerik programlama
tarafında
böyle bir
kod seçimi var
şimdi gelelim
standart kütüphanemize
biraz
standart kütüphanemizin
exception ile
ilişkisinden
bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
daha önce de
söylediğim gibi
standart kütüphanede
bir
exception
hiyerarşisi var
en tepede
stud exception
isimli bir sınıf var
sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
exception
sınıfları var
ve standart kütüphane
gerek
standart kütüphanenin
sınıflarının
üye fonksiyonlarından
bazıları
gerek
operatör seviyesindeki
bazı işlemler
dilim verdiği
garanti altında
belirli sınıflar
türünden
exception
throw ediyorlar
bu sınıflar
şu açıdan önemli
a
biz yazdığımız
kodlarda
verdiğimiz basit
örneklerde
dahi
doğrudan
standart kütüphanenin
bir
exception
sınıfı
hiyerarşisindeki
türünden
exception
throw edebiliriz
örneklerde
dikkat ettiniz
bazı örneklerde
runtime error
throw ettim
bazı örneklerde
yanlış hatırlıyor
olabilirim ama
invalid
argument
türünden
exception
throw ettim
bizde
yazdığımız
kodlarda
arkadaşlar
bu sınıflar
türünden
doğal olarak
exception
throw edebiliriz
artı
çoğunlukla
yapıldığı gibi
böyle bir
mecburiyet
olmasa da
kendi
oluşturduğumuz
custom
exception
sınıflarını
standart
kütüphanenin
exception
yiyerarşisi
içindeki
sınıflardan
birinden
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde
edebiliriz
bu da çok
yaygın
örneğin
date
sınıfının
yanlış
geçersiz
bir tarihi
oluşması
durumunda
bir
exception
throw
etmesini
isteyin
bu durumda
ona özgü
custom
bir exception
sınıfını
örneğin
bu yiyerarşide
size uygun
gelen
örneğin
runtime
error
sınıfı
türünden
bir
exception
sınıfı
oluşturarak
o sınıf
türünden
exception
throw
edebilirsiniz
şimdi bu
exception
sınıflarının
en tepedeki
exception
sınıfı
başlık
dosyası
içinde
bazıları
özellikle
bu
logic
error ve
runtime
error
onlar
stud
accept
başlık
dosyası
içinde
yani
onları
kullanıyorsanız
o başlık
dosyasını
include
etmeniz
gerekiyor
ama
bazıları da
farklı farklı
mesela
operatör seviyesinde
exception
throw
edilen
operatör
seviyesindeki
işlemlerden
o exception
throw
edenler
ayrı
başlık
dosyalarında
örneğin
new
başlık
dosyasında
ya da
efendim
type
info
başlık
dosyasında
olması
gibi
bazı
exception
belirli
sınıflara
özgü
olduğu için
örneğin
arkadaşlar
multi
thread
programlama
concurrency
konusunda
gönderilen
bazı
exception
var
onların
ilgili
sınıfları
türünden
efendim
bazıları
örneğin
variant
sınıfının
gönderdiği
bir exception
tipik olarak
variant
başlık
dosyası
içinde
ya da
optional
başlık
dosyasındaki
optional
sınıfının
gönderdiği
exception
işte burada
görüyorsunuz
bad
optional
access
tipik olarak
ilgili sınıfın
başlık
dosyasında
ama bunların
hepsini tabi
ezberlemeniz
gerekmiyor
gerektiğinde
bir referans
kitabına
kaynağında
cppreference.com'a
falan bakarak
arkadaşlar
bulabilirsiniz
ama
şimdi standart
kütüphaneyi
kullanırken
standart
kütüphanenin
fonksiyonlarının
ya da
operatörlerin
hangi koşulda
hangi exception'ı
throw ettiğini
bilmek
önemli olabilir
çünkü o exception
throw ederse
yakalanmazsa
sizin programınız
sonlanacak
öyle değil mi?
birkaç tane
örnek vereyim
arkadaşlar
en basit örnek
zaten bizim
string sınıfındaydı
o örneği
vermiştik
ama bir kez
daha vermek
istiyorum
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi?
yazının
karakterine
erişmek için
bir
index
operatör
fonksiyonu
substript
operatör
fonksiyonu
vardı
bir de
et isimli
bir fonksiyon
vardı
string
şöyle yazalım
str
necati
ergin
str
köşeli parantez
c
bu
undefined
diyebilir
iken
yani burada
bir exception
gönderilmiyor
iken
arkadaşlar
örneğin
add fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yaparsam
add fonksiyonu
index'in
geçerse olması
durumunda
out of range
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw ediyordu
az önceki
hiyerarşiye
bakarsanız
out of range'in
logic error
sınıfından
kalıtım yolu
ile ergedildiğini
görüyorsunuz
logic error de
exception
sınıfından
arkadaşlar
bu arada
bu ayrım
aslında
logic error
şu anlamda
programın
lojik
yapısından
kaynaklanıyor
pekala
her şey
%100
kontrol edilseydi
bu exception'ler
oluşmayacaktı
bu hata durumları
anlamında
aynı koda
geri dönüyorum
bu kez
exception'ı
logic error
ile yakalıyorum
yine exception'in
yakalandığını
göreceksiniz
exception'in
kendi sınıfı
olan
out of range
ile yakalıyorum
yine
yakalandığını
görüyorsunuz
ama
arkadaşlar
mesela
string sınıfı
ile ilgili
bambaşka
bir
exception
göstermek
istiyorum
biraz
beklerseniz
evet
mesela bazı işlemler
lang terror
isimli
sınıf türünden
exception
throw ediyor
aslında
lang terror
şöyle bir
exception
string'in
uzunluğu
olabilecek
en büyük
uzunluğun
üstüne
çıkması
durumunda
arkadaşlar
lang terror
throw ediyor
hata onu
beraber
yazabiliriz
örneğimi
bulamadım
şöyle yazalım
arkadaşlar
str'nin
diyorum
str
max size
a
evet
str
assign
buraya kadar
bir
yerleyelim
gösterme imkanı
da tam
olmayabilir
evet
güzel bir örnek
yazmıştım
aslında
şu örneği
kurulamaya
çalışıyorum
öyle bir
string
oluşturacağım
ki
o string'in
bir
üye fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
o üye fonksiyon
mesela
assign
fonksiyonu
ya da
append
fonksiyonu
string'in
taşıyabileceği
uzunluğun
üstünde
bir uzunluk
oluşturacak
bu durumda
lang terror
throw edecek
aslında
biraz doğru
açsam
yapabilirim
ama zamanda
kaybetmek
istemiyorum
yazılmış
örneği
bulayım
mesela
bir
tamam
şimdi oldu
ya
şöyle yazayım
string
ptr
str'nin
max size
auto
sz
string
s
efendim
sz
eksi
artı
yüz
böyle
falan
gösterebilirim
sanıyorum
işte
mesela
böyle bir örnekte
ne yapacak
belki deminde
onu
throw etti
lang terror
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw edecek
yani string
string sınıfında
iki tane önemli
exception var
biri
out of range
onu konuştuk
diğeri de
stringin büyüğe fonksiyonu
stringi taşıyabileceği
uzunluğun
üstünde bir
uzunlukta
yazı tutmaya
zorlarsa
orada da
lang terror
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw ediyor
işte lang terror
yine
out of range
olduğu gibi
logic error
sınıfında
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
bir
sınıf
arkadaşlar
bunun dışında
operatör
nivin
throw ettiği
ne var
bedallog var
birkaç tane
örnek verelim
mesela
bedallog'a
bir örnek vereceğim
şimdi
şöyle yapalım
bir tane
try
bloğumuz
olsun
yine
bedallog
sınıfı
türünden
catch
parametresi
olsun
bedallog
burada
bir döngü
oluşturalım
arkadaşlar
on bin
ve
niv
ifadesiyle
int
köşeli
parantez
diyelim ki
çarpı
buradan elde
ettiğimiz
adresi
terleyici
uyarı
mesaj
vermesin
diye
tane
vektör
oluşturayım
tut
vektör
int
yıldız
vek
pushback
yapayım
yani
vektörü
ekleyeyim
ibek'in
pushback'i
evet
stud vektörün
int yıldız
açılımı
vektör
başlık
dosyası
dahil edilmiş
ibek'in
pushback'i
niye altını
çizecek
altını
bir şey yok
ama
bakalım
yine de
vekmiş
ismi
ben dedim
neye altını
hatta
şöyle
stud
see out
her başarılı
tahsisat
için
standart
output'a
bir nokta
karakteri
yazdıralım
enide sonunda
benle kalanı
yeterli
olmayınca
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
bir
bedallok
throw
edecek
evet
şimdi
try
bedallok
load
new
int
az mı
geldi
bir daha
bakalım
for int
debug mode'unu da
bir alayım
bir eksiklik
görüyor musunuz
kodda
ben görmüyorum
evet
bazen bir şeyler
beklediğiniz gibi
olmuyor
biraz büyütelim
artık
müsaadenle
exception
throw
it
ben bir şey
gözden kaçırılıyor
bakıyorum
evet
yani
operatör new
fonksiyon
aşırısız
olduğunda
operatör new
fonksiyonları
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
bedallok
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw
ediyor
evet
normal bir türlü
exception
throw
ettiremedik
burada
evet
1 milyon
çarpı
evet
neyse o çalışır
dursun
bu en
tipik
exception
en çok
throw
edilen
exception
lardan biri
bedallok
bu
dinamik
bellek yönetimi
ve dinamik
ömürlü
nesneler
konusunda
üstünde
epey
duracağız
bedallok
exception
larının
bunun dışında
birkaç örnek
daha vermek
istiyorum
mesela
arkadaşlar
git set
sınıfı
doğrudan
yarın örneği
kopyalayayım
çok da vakit
kaybetmek
istemiyorum
artık
evet
birkaç tane
örnek
mesela
varyant
sınıfı
arkadaşlar
üstünde
çok duracağız
kursun
ikinci
yarısında
c++
17 ile
eklenen
çok önemli
bir sınıf
c++
üretimde de
kullanılmaya
çok aday
bir sınıf
arkadaşlar
varyant
c'deki
unionların
arkadaşlar
tag unionların
ehlileştirilmiş
hali
type safe
mesela
böyle bir
sınıf türünden
bir nesne
int de tutabilir
float da tutabilir
şu anda int tutuyor
fakat
varyantın
varyant nesnesinin
değerine erişmek
istediğinizde
eğer
o noktada
tuttuğu
değer
ona alternatif
deniyor
seçtiğiniz
tür
değilse
bad
variant
access
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw
ediyor
mesela
burada
int tuttuğu zaman
bir exception
throw
etmeyecek
cat
fonksiyonu
kodu
tamamen
anlamanız
önemli
değil
arkadaşlar
ama exception
throw
etmeyecek
ama int
tutarken
ben onu
float
tutuyormuş
muamelesi
yaparsam
bad
variant
access
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw
edecek
mesela
bakın
şu örnek
cppreference.com'dan
invalid
argument'ın
throw edildiği
yerlere örnek
olarak vermiş
gayet de güzel bir örnek
mesela bakın
bit set sınıfı
az önce bahsettiğim
şöyle yapalım
bunları şu anda
aklınıza tutmanıza
gerek yok
ama tipik örnekler
mesela bit set sınıfının
constar yıldız
parametre gibi
bir konstruktörü
var
arkadaşlar
ama bu
konstruktör
bir yazıdan
alıyor
bitleri
bu durumda
yazının da
sadece sıfır ve
bir karakterlerinden
oluşması
gerekiyor
oysa şimdi
yazıda
iki karakterinin
de olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
bu durumda
bit set sınıfının
konstruktörü
invalid
argument
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw ediyor
bakın
konstruktörün
exception
throw etmesine
çok tipik bir örnek
yine başka bir örnek
bu sefer
konstruktör değil
izleyin
bu da string sınıfı ile ilgili
bu da güzel
evet
arkadaşlar
standart
tüphanenin
s2i
fonksiyonu
string to
integer
stringten
integer'e
dönüşüm yapıyor
ama string
eğer
bir
integer'e
dönüştürülecek
karakterler
içermiyorsa
mesela
bakınız
şöyle olsaydı
exception
throw etmeyecekti
bir hata
durumu yok
ama
geçersiz
tam sayı
sözluluğu
tam sayıya
dönüştürülemeyecek
arkadaşlar
bir
değerse
gördüğünüz gibi
exception
throw etti
aynı
şekilde
bu seferde
s2f
fonksiyonu
bir tane
c-spring
argüman olarak
aldığını
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
evet
geçerli bir
dönüşüm olmadığı
için
yine
invalid
argument
throw
edecek
örnekleri
çoğaltmak
mümkün
mesela
optional
sınıfı
tipik bir örnek
onu da ben
yazayım
bari
optional'da
gerçekten çok
kullanımı
çok artan
bir sınıf
c++17 ile
dile eklenmesi
ile birlikte
optional
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
ya bir değere
sahip
ya da bir değere
değil
yani bir değere
sahip olması
kadar
değere sahip
olmaması
da
doğal
mesela
optional
int
açılımı
türünden
x
şu anda
bir değere
sahip
arkadaşlar
x'in
value
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
auto
value
eşittir
ve
value
değerini
yazdırıyorum
value
optional
meselesi
bir değere
sahip
olmasın
onu da
hatta
şöyle
sinleyebilirsiniz
if
x
operator
bool
fonksiyonu
var
cout
bir değere
sahip
bu da
neye güzel bir örnek
operator
bool
fonksiyonu
bir örnek
aslında
burada
çağırılan
sınıfın
operator
bool
fonksiyonu
yine aynı
sınıfın
has value
isimli bir
fonksiyonu
da var
her ikisi de
bir değere
sahip olup
olmadığına
sınıyor
bir değere
sahip
beni sorunuza
cevap vereceğim
önce şu örneği
bitireyim
else
siyah
değere
sahip
değil
şu anda bakalım
değere sahip
değil
peki değere sahip
değilken
value
fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
ve
bir try
blue
için
alalım
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
bir exception
gönderildi
gönderilen
exception'i
da
yakaladık
aslında
gönderilen
exception
buradan da
bir
görelim
bad
optional
access
sınıfı
türünden
o da
doğrudan
exception
sınıfından
kalıtımla
elde edilmiş
yani exception'la
yakalayabilirim
ya da
kendi sınıfı olan
bad
optional
access'le
yakalayabilirim
deniz'in sorusu
hoda
try
catch
blue
yazmak
runtime'da
bizi yavaşlatır mı
şimdi
sorunun cevabını
hemen devamını
okumadan
şöyle vereyim
modern sistemlerde
exception
trope edilmediği
zaman
arkadaşlar
kayda
değer
maliyeti yok
yani
hatta
modern
derleyişlerde
herhangi bir
şekilde
exception
gönderilmediği
zaman
exception
kodlarının
bir maliyeti
yok
zero'ya
yakın
zero olmaz
hiçbir zaman
ama
exception'in
yakalanması
durumunda
tabii ki
ilave bir
maliyeti
var
mesela
s2 yerine
her karakteri
tek tek
kontrol edip
valid değilse
conversion
yapmayan
bir fonksiyonu
biz mi
yapmalıyız
şimdi bu
duruma göre
değişir
yani tek bir
cevabı
olamaz
arkadaşlar
normalde
bir fonksiyona
geçerli
argüman
göndermek
sizin
kontrolünüzde
yani
eğer
siz bir
fonksiyonu
çağırıyorsanız
o fonksiyonda
diyelim ki
bir fonksiyonda
split string
göndereceksiniz
fakat
split string
geçerli
nitelikte
değil
bundan siz
sorumlusunuz
bu aslında
bir programlama
hatası
ama
bu tür
hatalar
api sınırlarının
dışından
geldiğinde
sizin
yapacak
bir şeyiniz
kalmıyor
dolayısıyla
exception
throw
ederse
o
exception
ile uğraşmak
sizinle
ilgili
yani
yazdığınız fonksiyonun
da exception
gönderip
göndermeyeceği
onu da daha önce
konuşmuştuk
o da sözleşmeye
bağlı
yani dar
sözleşme mi
geniş
yani her
fonksiyonun
parametresi
geçerli bir input
oluşturmuyor diye
bütün fonksiyonlar
exception
throw etmeli
böyle bir
saptama da
doğru değil
dolayısıyla
sorumuzun
tek bir cevabı
yok
duruma göre
farklı farklı
stratejiler
kullanılabilir
evet
birkaç tane
örnek verdim
standart
kütüphanenin
gönderdiği
exception
lara
zaten bu
sınıfları
incelerken
her biri
için
bu
öğreneceğimiz
sınıfların
STL'de
gerek
konteyner
sınıfları
olsun
gerek
diğer yardımcı
sınıflar
olsun
ve
bundan sonra
öğreneceğimiz
operatörler
dahil
exception
göndermeleri
durumunda
hangi
türden
exception
gönderdiklerini
hangi
koşulda
exception
gönderdiklerini
bilmek
zorundayız
bir sınıf
için
stud exception
den türemiş
özel exception
sınıfımızı
yazmanın
bir dezavantajı
var mı
arkadaşlar
yazmanın
bir dezavantajı
olduğunu düşünmüyorum
avantajı
olduğu yerler
var
çünkü
o sınıfla
ilgili
oluşturacağınız
exception
ayrı
olarak
ne yapılabilir
keç edilebilir
yani
siz örneğin
belirli yerde
bir try
bloğu
oluşturduğunuzda
sizin sınıfınız için
ayrı bir
catch
bloğu
oluşturabilirsiniz
ama
bir dezavantajı
var mı
derken
buradaki
vurgu
ne yönde
bir sınıf için
stud exception
türemiş
özel exception
sınıfımızı
yazmanın
bir dezavantajı
var mı
dezavantajı
yok bence
ama
o kodu da
doğru bir şekilde
yazmak
gerekiyor
stud exception
den
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde etmek
biraz daha
radikal
bir tavır
bence
stud exception
den ziyade
runtime
error den
exception
sınıfınızı
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edebilirsiniz
ya da duruma göre
hatta
örneğin gerçekten
out of range ile
doğru bir yaklaşım
olup olmadığı
konusunda
kararsızım
yani
kendi exception
sınıfınızı
oluşturmanın mı
doğru bir yaklaşım
olup olmadığı
konusunda
yoksa
hayır ben
kendi exception
sınıfımı
oluşturuyorum ama
exception
den kalıtım
yoluyla mı
elde edeyim
yoksa
doğrudan mı
yazayım
ben ikisinin de
doğru ya da
yanlış olarak
nitelenebileceğini
düşünmüyorum
yani
bu tamamen
kullandığınız
strateji
vereceğiniz
neyi öncelediğinize
bağlı olarak
karar değişebilir
yani birine mutlak
yanlış birine
daha iyi birine
daha kötü demek
mümkün olduğunu
sanmıyorum açıkçası
kendi sanmıyorum
evet
peki
şimdi
birkaç konumuz
daha var
exception
handling ile ilgili
ona da bakalım
ve ondan sonra
artık
arada verdikten sonra
bu generic
programlama
tarafına
geçelim
arkadaşlar
iki tane
daha araç var
aslında
bunlar
özellikle
concurrency
konusunda
bir tanesi
çok önemli
şimdi bazen
yakaladığınız
bir exception'ı
bulunduğunuz
yerde değil de
başka bir yerde
handle etmek
istiyorsunuz
mesela
concurrency tarafında
bu çok sık
duyulan bir ihtiyaç
standart kütüphane de
bir ele öğelerinde
bunu sağlıyor
mesela bir
thread'de
bir exception
olduğunda
o
thread
çalışırken
o exception'ın
dışarı sızması
yine
terminate
fonksiyonunun
çağrılmasına
neden oluyor
ama siz
o exception'ı
orada yakalayıp
ondan sonra
o thread'in
çalışması
tamamlandıktan sonra
thread'i oluşturan
main thread'de
ya da onun
parent'ında
o exception'ı
handle etmek
isteyebiliyorsunuz
concurrency
olması da
gerekmiyor
illa
yani
o exception'ı
bir yerde
yakalayıp
farklı bir
kod noktasında
onu
handle etmek
isteyebiliyorsunuz
bunun için
standart kütüphanenin
biraz belki
başlangıçta
zor gelecek
bir sınıfı
var
pointer gibi
kullanılabilen
aslında
pointer-light bir
sınıf
bu sınıfın
ismi
exception
PTR
ileride
önemi
epey anlaşılacak
şu an için
sadece biraz
değineceğim
tekrar söylüyorum
çünkü bu
sınıfın
önemi
daha çok
concurrency
tarafında
arkadaşlar
exception
PTR
polymorphik
bir pointer
gibi davranıyor
yani siz
exception
PTR
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesnede
bir
exception
nesnesini
polymorphik
olarak tutabiliyorsunuz
olarak tutmaktan
kastım şu
yani
exception
belirli bir
hiyerarşide
ve o
hiyerarşideki
örneğin
türemiş
sınıflardan
birinde
siz
exception
PTR
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesneyle
o exception
tutarsanız
sarmalarsanız
ya da
pointer
gibi onu
göstermesini
sağlarsanız
başka bir
kontekste
dinamik
türü
koruyabiliyorsunuz
şimdi
exception
yakalayıp
dinamik
türünde
koruyarak
başka bir
yerde
handle
etmek için
şöyle bir
yapı
kullanılıyor
arkadaşlar
önce
her zaman
olduğu gibi
hata gönderme
potansiyelinde
olan kodu
bir
try blue
içine
alıyoruz
hatayı
yakalıyoruz
ve yakaladığımız
hata nesnesini
bir
exception
PTR'ye
bağlıyoruz
yani
exception
PTR
nesnesinin
onu
göstermesini
sağlıyoruz
sonra o
exception
PTR
nesnesini
başka bir
koda
göndererek
onun
tuttuğu
exception'i
tekrar
göndermesini
sağlayıp
orada
o exception'i
handle
edebiliyoruz
başlangıçta
biraz tuhaf
gibi görünse de
birkaç örnek
yaparsak
en azından
bazı şeyleri
sezebilirsiniz
mesela bakın
şimdi
main
fonksiyonu
içinde
bir try
blue
olsun
arkadaşlar
exception'i
herhangi bir
şekilde
yakalayabilirsiniz
izleyin
catch-off
blue
kullandım
burada
diyelim ki
ben
string
nesnem
olsun
tuttuğu
yazı
cengizhan
yazısı
olsun
exception
throw
ölçekli
kod
oluşturayım
auto
c
eşittir
stl'nin
eti
burada
exception gönderecek
şimdi biz burada
exception'i
yakalayacağız
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bir tane
exception
ptr
nesnem
olsun
stl
exception
ptr
ep
evet
bakın şimdi
exception ptr'ye
dönüştürmek için
sınıfın
bir tane
global fonksiyon
var
free
function var
fonksiyonun ismi
current
exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
current
exception
fonksiyonu
size
bir
exception
ptr'ye
veriyor
hangi hata
yakalanmışsa
bu hata
nesnesini
polimorfik
olarak tutan
bir exception
ptr'ye
nesnesi
veriyor
ve onu
bir başka
exception ptr
nesnesinde
tutabiliyorsunuz
şimdi bakın
burada hata
gönderildi
exception
trove edildi
burada
exception'i
yakaladım
şimdi ben
ep'yi
kullanarak
ep'yi örneğin
herhangi bir
fonksiyona
gönderebilirim
mesela
bir tane fonksiyonumuz
olsun
arkadaşlar
void
handle
exception
ismine bakmayın
fonksiyonun parametresi
exception ptr
kopyalama
maliyeti
düşük
o yüzden
kopyalama yoluyla
aktarılmasında
hiçbir sakınca yok
bu da
eptr
olsun
şimdi
exception ptr
nesnesi
null pointer
değerinde de
olabilir
bu da bir
nullable type
dolayısıyla
bir exception
ptr nesnesi
yakalanmış
bir exception'i
ya da bir exception'i
store etmiş
olabilir
onu taşıyabilir
ya da boş
durumda da
olabilir
o yüzden
çoğunlukla
ne yapıyoruz
arkadaşlar
boş mu
diye bir
kontrol
yapıyoruz
ve
eğer
doluysa
yine
standart
pipanenin
bir fonksiyonu
var
read
roll exception
burada iki tane
exception var
iki tane
global fonksiyon
var
bir
current exception
arkadaşlar
exception
exception'i
exception ptr'ye
dönüştüren
öbürü de
re-draw exception
bu da sizden bir
exception ptr
nesnesini
istiyor
ve onu
çağırdığınız noktada
throw ediyor
eptr
şimdi eğer
boş durumda
değilse
doluysa
re-draw exception
fonksiyonu
onu
adı üstünde
re-draw
edecek
throw edecek
dolayısıyla
ben burada
bir try bloğu
oluşturursam
bu kodu
bir try bloğu
içine alırsam
bakın
exception
başka bir
bağlamda
göndermiş
olmasına rağmen
exception'i
burada
handle
edebiliyorum
see out
exception
code
x'in
what'ı
thread'lerden
thread'in dışına da
exception'lar
standart kütüphanenin
öğelerinde
böyle aktarılıyor
aslında
arka planda
evet
eksik bir şey kaldı mı
bakalım
verleyip
çalıştırıyorum
evet
fonksiyonu
çağırmamışım
current
exception
neydi
fonksiyonun
ismi
handle
exception
ep
bakın
exception
yakalandı
ama
onun
olduğu
bağlamdan
başka bir
bağlamda
exception'i yakaladım
ara vermeden
mülakatlarda da
sorulan bir soru
soracağım size
çok güzel bir soru
aslında bu
bir c++
idiomuna ilişkin
arkadaşlar bir
exception
yiyerarşimiz var
mesela
class
xbase
der
public
xbase
class
der
böyle sınıflar var
soruyu önce anlamaya çalışın
bir tane de fonksiyon var
sizin şöyle bir işi başarmanız gerekiyor
bu fonksiyona
exception
yiyerarşisi içinden
arkadaşlar
bir
exception
göndereceksiniz
ve bu fonksiyonun
o türden
bir
exception'i
throw etmesini sağlayacaksınız
yani fonksiyonu örneğin
der 1
gönderirseniz
fonksiyon
der 1
sınıfa türünden
bir exception
gönderecek
der 2
gönderirseniz
sınıfa türünden
bir exception
gönderecek
arkadaşlar
bunu
sağlamanız
gerekiyor
evet
buradaki
idioma
polymorphic
exception
deniyor
bunu bir düşünmenizi
istiyorum
ben de bu arada
bir ara vereyim
saat
21.04
21.24
de devam edeceğiz
bir önceki
derste örneği
kurgulayamadım
nedense
ya da örneği
arada bıraktım
şimdi örneği
buraya kopyaladım
length
terörü
ilişkin
aslında son derece
basit
max size
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerini
kullanıyorum
bir değişkende
tutmam da
gerekmiyor
try
bloğu içinde
dikkat ederseniz
assign fonksiyonuna
max size
daha büyük bir değer
argüman olarak
gönderdim
ve bu durumda
tutabileceği
uzunluğun
daha üstünde
bir değer
oluştu
oluşmak
durumu
söz konusu
oldu ve
length
terör
throw etti
tabi length
terörüyle
yakalayabiliriz
onun taban
sınıfı
logic
terörüyle
yakalayabiliriz
ya da
efendim
exception
sınıfı
türünden
bir
catch
parametresiyle
yakalayabiliriz
şimdi
sorumuza geri dönelim
basit bir soru gibi
görünüyor ama
önemli bir idiom
dedim ki
bir
exception
taban
sınıfımız var
ve burada
bir
yererşi var
bu
polimorfik bir
sınıf olsun
public
virtual
e-base
destructor
eşittir
default
bu sınıftan
kalıtımla elde edilen
exception sınıfları var
class
ne olsun
der bir
public
e-base
er-2
er-3
şimdi amaç şu
elimizde bir fonksiyon var
bu fonksiyona yakalanmış bir hatayı göndermiyoruz
eğer zaten
bir hatayı yakalamış olsaydık
bu fonksiyonda
onu
retro edip
onun
dinamit türünü
koruyabilirdik
ama
hata nesnesinin
kendisi elimizde
yani örneğin
şöyle bir hata nesnesi
oluşturduk
der bir türünden
x
fonksiyona
bunu argüman olarak gönderiyorum
fonksiyonu çağırdığım noktada
mesela main fonksiyonu içinde
der bir sınıfı türünden
x
tabi parametresi
bu türden olacak
ve bunu
try blue için alıyorum
ben hangi sınıf türünden
exception gönderirsem
bu fonksiyon
o sınıf türünden
exception'e
throw edecek
bunu da şöyle anlayabilirim
catch
der bir
ref
efendim
şuna der bir diyelim
der bir ref
ismini de kullanmayacağıma göre
isim oluşturmam da
gerekmiyor
see out
der bir
kod
çok kısa yazı yazdıralım
der iki
der iki kod
der üç
bir de catch
all
bloğumuz olsun
other
exception
hi
şimdi başlangıçta
çözümün şu olduğunu
düşünebilirsiniz
ne var
fonksiyonun parametresini
taban sınıf türünden
yapalım
exception
değil
taban sınıfın
ismi
e-base
efendim
ref
x
burada örneğin şöyle
exception'ı
throw edersek
dinamik tür korunur mu
cevap
hayır
foo'yu
çağırıyorum
der bir
eğer istediğim
olursa
programın akışının
buraya girmesi
gerekecek
yani istediğimin
olup olmadan da
böyle sınıyorum
terliyorum
gördüğünüz gibi
catch all
bloğuna giriyor
çünkü
burada
dinamik tür
korunmuyor
derli içi
x'in türüne
bakacak
e-base türünden
olduğu için
exception
throw edecek
meselenin ne olduğunu
anladık mı
böyle politikacıların
söylediği gibi
meselemizin ne olduğu
anlaşıldı mı
bunu yapmaya
çalışıyoruz
şöyle yapsak
yine olmaz
değil mi
burada bir
try bloğ oluştursak
throw
x
bunu yakalayıp
re-throw etsek
yine aynı şey
olacak
catch
çünkü gönderilen
exception
e-base türünden
çözüm önerisi
olan var mı
aklınıza gelen
bir şey var mı
bunun nasıl
yapılabileceği
konusunda
cevap
read
roll
kullanamam ki
burada
gönderilen bir
exception yok
yani
şöyle yazarsam
olsam
gönderilmeyen
bir exception
olduğu için
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılır
anlaşıldı mı
yani bu
çözüm
değil
cevap
yine
virtual
dispatchten
faydalanmak
bakın
ne yapıyoruz
taban
sınıfı
bir tane
sanal
fonksiyon
ekliyoruz
virtual
void
race
tipik isimde
bu
bu taban
sınıfın
sanal
fonksiyonu
throw
yıldız
dis
dolayısıyla
yıldız
dis'in
türü ne ise
o türden
exception
throw
veriyor
türemiş
sınıflar
ne yapacak
bunu
override
edecek
public
override
takip edebiliyor muyuz
her taban
sınıfı
kendi sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw
ediyor
o zaman
çözüm ne
fonksiyonu
tabi bunun bir de
const overload
olduğunu yazmakta
fayda var
ama konumuz o
olmadığı için
onu göstermiyorum
burada
throw
ifadesi olarak
kullanmak yerine
sanal
fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum
şimdi oldu
şık
değil mi
bu videoma
polymorphic
exception
videomu
deniyor
bakın
der bir
kod
per iki
anlaşıldı mı
biraz karmaşık
gibi görünüyor
ama
bence
çok şık
çözüm
arkadaşlar
bir exception
videomu daha
göstermek istiyorum
eğer kafanız
karışmayacaksa
şimdi
bu biraz daha
kafanızı karıştırabilir
dikkatli izlemek
gerekiyor
diyelim ki
bizim
belirli sınıflar
türünden
belirli
exception
sınıflarımız var
bunlar ayrı ayrı
sınıflar
ben kendi örneğimi
buraya kopyalayacağım
bu videomun ismi de
exception
dispatcher
dispatch gönderme
anlamında
biliyorsunuz
net exception
ayrı bir
exception
sınıfı
er
exception
ayrı bir
sınıfı
csd
exception
ayrı bir
sınıfı
siz şimdi
birden fazla
kaynak
kod
noktasında
örneğin
punk isimli
fonksiyon içinde
bir exception
bu sınıflar
türünden
exception'e
müdahale etmek
istiyorsunuz
dolayısıyla örneğin
burada bir
try bloğu var
try bloğunu
izleyen de
catch
bloğları var
normalde
şunu yazmanız
gerekiyor
catch
diyelim ki
bunun parametresi
net exception
türünden
bir başka
catch
bloğu
diğer sınıf
türünden
catch
parametresine
sahip
bu da
diyelim ki
diğer sınıf
türünü
yani
burada
bu sınıflar
türünden
exception
gönderildiği
zaman
siz o
exception'i
buradaki
gibi
handle
edeceksiniz
yani
net exception
sınıfı
türünden
gönderilirse
buradaki
bot çalışacak
buraya kadar
tamam mı
ama
şimdi
bunu
birden fazla
noktada
yapmanız
gerekiyor
örneğin
fun fonksiyonu
içinde de
böyle bir
try
catch
bloğları
full fonksiyonu
içinde de
birden fazla
noktada
bu durumda
bu kodu
tekrar etmek
gerekiyor
problemin
ne olduğunu
anladınız mı
ama
siz şimdi
bu kodu
tekrar etmeyen
bir çözüm
arıyorsunuz
ne olabilir
çözüm
yani her
defasında
bu kodu
tekrar etmeyecek
bir çözüm
aslında buna
bir gönderme
yapmıştım
şimdi
onun
önemini
göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
ben
bunu bir
fonksiyona
taşısam
diyelim ki
fonksiyonun ismi
handle
exception
olsa
fakat bu
fonksiyonu
bir
catch
bloğundan
çağırsam
o zaman
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
retro
edebilir
miyim
soruya cevap
vermeye çalışayım
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
retro
edebilir
miyim
edebilirim
ama tabi bu fonksiyonun
sadece
catch
bloğundan
çağırılması
gerekir
o zaman
buraya bir
try bloğu
oluştursam
içinde
exception'i
retro
etsem
ve buradaki
arkadaşlar
kodu
buraya
taşısam
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
şimdi
bu
müdahaleyi
yapacağım
her yerde
try bloğunu
aldım ya
bu kodu
tekrar
etmek
yerine
bunu
catch
all
da yakalasam
ve
burada
handle
exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırsam
bu da şık
bir
çözüm
anladık
mı
bu durumda
handle
exception
catch
bloğundan
çağrıldığı
için
retro
ettiğimde
aynı
exception
gönderilecek
ve
buradaki
kod
çalışacak
şimdi
bunu
nerede
yaparsam
yapayım
aslında
aynı
catch
bloğlarını
kullanmış
olacağım
buna da
ne deniyor
exception
dispatcher
gidiyor
mu
exception
handlingle ilgili
birkaç tane
daha
idiomatik
yapı
var
onları
normalde
ileri
C++
kursunda
anlatıyorum
bir de
aslında
bir öğe
daha var
değinmemiz
gereken
fakat onu
başka bir
derse
bırakacağım
nested
exception
arkadaşlar
bazen
şöyle bir
ihtiyaç
doğuyor
siz bir
exception
yakalıyorsunuz
fakat
yakaladığınız
exception
kendisiyle
birlikte
kendinize
ayrı bir
exception
göndermek
istiyorsunuz
yani daha
yukarıdaki
katmanlar
sizin
yakaladığınız
exception'a
ve
sizin
gönderdiğiniz
exception'a
ikisine
birden
ulaşacaklar
ikisi hakkında
da bilgi
edinecekler
işte
standart
kütüphane
bunun için
nested
exception
isimli
bir
araç
veriyor
aslında
çok basit
olarak bir
göstereyim
daha sonra
belki
ayrıntıda
çok da fazla
bir ayrıntısı
da yok
aslında
arkadaşlar
burada
yine
standart
kütüphanenin
bir global
fonksiyonu
var
global
fonksiyonun
ismi
free
function'un
ismi
throw
with
nested
throw
with
nested
fonksiyonuna
siz
normal
throw
statement'ta
olduğu gibi
kendiniz
kendi
exception'ınızı
veriyorsunuz
catch
flow
içinde
ama
yakaladığınız
exception'la
birlikte
yine
bu
kursa
muhtemelen
değinemeyeceğiz
bir
mixing sınıf
oluşturuluyor
o mixing
sınıf
türünden
yani
her iki
sınıfa da
ulaşım
imkanı
veren
bir
sınıf
türünden
exception
gönderiyor
şöyle
basit bir
örnek
üstünde
görelim
en azından
bir fikriniz
olsun
detaylı
değinmesek
de
biraz
sabır
olalım
evet
bakın şimdi
şu global
fonksiyonu
sonra anlatacağım
baz isimli
bir fonksiyon
var
runtime
error
throw
etli
bar
fonksiyonu
baz fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
exception'i
yakaladı
ama
bakın
throw
with
nested
fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
throw
with
nested
fonksiyonuna
kendi gönderdiği
exception'ı
göndermek istediği
argüman olarak
geçti
şimdi bu
true
with
nested
fonksiyonu
aslında
bir
mixing
sınıf
türünden
exception'ı
throw
etti
böylece
bunu yakalayan
aslında bir
şekilde
hem yakalanan
runtime
error'ü
yani buradaki
exception'ı
hem de
sizin
nested
olarak
verdiğiniz
işsel olarak
kendi exception'inizi
birlikte elde etme
şansına
sahip olacak
hatta bir kademe
daha ileri
gittik
full fonksiyonu
full da
barı çağırdı
ve
full fonksiyonu
içinde de
yine
true
with nested'la
runtime
error
türünden
bir exception
daha gönderdim
yani
ilk gönderilen
exception var
buradaki
exception
arkadaşlar
bunların bu arada
aynı türden
olması da
gerekmiyor
ikinci gönderdiğim
exception
true
with nested'la
gönderdiğim
runtime
error
yazılar
değişip
o yüzden
daha iyi
görebileceksiniz
ve
üçüncüsü
şimdi
full fonksiyonu
çağırdım
ve
exception'ı
yakaladım
şimdi
burada yakaladığım
exception
bir mixing
klastöründen
dolayısıyla
sarmalanan
bütün exception'lara
ulaşma
olanağı veriyor
o
yakalanmış
exception'lara
ulaşmak için de
şöyle bir yol
izliyoruz
yine
global bir
fonksiyon var
ismi
read row
if nested
arkadaşlar
stud exception'ı
alıyor
eğer
sarmalanmış
bir exception
varsa
onu da yakalıyor
böylece
recursive olarak
dikkat ederseniz
bakın
önce exception'ı
aldım
işledim
sonra
yeni bir
try blue
oluşturdum
o try blue
içinde
retrow
if nested'ı
çağırdım
eğer nested
bir exception
varsa
burası
yakaladı
burada
yine
recursive
olarak
print exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
böylece
her
çağırdığımda
o nested
derinliğindeki
bütün
exception'ları
tek tek
yakalayacağım
en son
sarmalanmış
başka bir
exception
kalmayınca
arkadaşlar
buradaki
try blue
bir exception
göndermeyecek
ve
print exception
fonksiyonundan
çıkılacak
yani burada
önemli olan
şunu anlamanız
standart kütüphane
bize
bu
nested exception
throw with nested
ve
retrow with nested
fonksiyonlarıyla
bir exception'ı
tutarak
onunla
başka bir exception'ı
birlikte
sarmalama
olanağı
veriyor
exception from
fo
nested exception
from bar
from
bas
yani en son
yakaladığımız
noktada
gönderilen
mixing sınıf
türünden
exception'ı
kullanarak
onun için
sarmalanmış
bütün exception'lara
erişebiliyoruz
bazen bu
gerçekten
gerekiyor
yani
ben exception'ı
yakalıyorum
ama
benim gönderdiğim
exception'i
yakalayacak
koda
kendi yakaladığım
exception'ı da
göndermek
istiyorum
kendi exception'ımla
birlikte
arkadaşlar
böylece
biraz uzun oldu
ama
exception handling
konusunun
sonuna geldik
diyebiliriz
tabi
şöyle 4-5 tane
daha
exception
idiomuna
değinmek
vardı
ama
bir yerde
kesmemiz
gerekiyor
artık
şimdi
konu
radikal bir şekilde
değişiyor
ve
jenerik programlama
tarafına
geçiyoruz
önce jenerik
programlama
ne demek
yani bu
terim ne
anlamda
kullanılıyor
bizim
Türkçe'deki
bence en iyi
karşılığı
türden
bağımsız
programlama
yani
öyle
kodlar ki
bu kodlar
farklı farklı
türlere
hizmet verebilecek
nitelikte
bu bir fonksiyon
olabilir
sınıf olabilir
ya da başka bir
kod
olabilir
arkadaşlar
aslında jenerik
programlamaya ilişkin
tek bir araç seti
yok
mesela fonksiyonları
düşünelim
fonksiyonların
birden fazla türe
hizmet verebilmesinin
yollarından biri
bizim
c'deki
primitif yolumuz
bunu da
gerektiğinde
kullanıyoruz
değil mi
yani
void pointer
kullanmak
eğer siz
bir fonksiyonun
parametresini
void pointer
yaparsanız
bu fonksiyona
herhangi türden
bir nezdenin
adresiyle
çağrı yapabilirsiniz
bu fonksiyon
gönderdiğiniz
nesnenin
türünü
bilmez
ama
adresi
kullanarak
muhtemelen
fonksiyona
gönderdiğiniz
diğer
argüman olan
öğeleri
kullanarak
genelleştirilmiş
türden bağımsız
bir takım işlemler
yapabilir
mesela
en tipik örneği
c'nin
standart kütüphanesinden
gelen
q sort
fonksiyonu
eminim
c kursuna katılanlar
zaten biliyordur
ama c kodu yazan
arkadaşlar da
q sort
fonksiyonunu
defalarca
çağırmışlardır
q sort ne yapıyor
türden bağımsız
bir diziyi
sıralıyor
q sortu
bilmeyen
duymayan
var mı
şöyle bir
hatırlatmak
gerekirse
std
lib
başlık dosyasında
q sort
birinci parametresi
sıralanacak
dizinin adresi
ikinci parametresi
sıralanacak
dizinin
boyutu
üçüncü parametresi
sıralanacak
dizinin
bir elemandan
size of'u
ve dördüncü parametresi
callback
function
yani
dizinin
elemanlarını
karşılaştırmakta
kullanılacak
fonksiyonun
adresi
arkadaşlar
o temel
c kursunda
jenerik
boyut yıldız
parametreli
çok sayıda
fonksiyon yazdık
mesela bakınız
en tipik örnek
boyut
g swap
tabi bunun
imkanları der
fonksiyon
türün ne olduğunu
bilmiyor
aslında bu tür
fonksiyonlar
aldıkları
adresteki
nesnenin
türünü bilmeden
onu
berlekte
bir blok
olarak kabul ediyor
ve o blok
üstünde
işlem yapıyor
mesela
en tipik örnek
c'de çok
kullandığımız
bir fonksiyon
türden
bağımsız
swap
fonksiyonu
void
yıldız
vp1
void
yıldız
vp2
aynı türden
iki tane
nesnenin
adresini
göndereceğim
o adresteki
nesneleri
takas edecek
fonksiyona
üçüncü bir
parametre koyuyorum
c kodu olduğunu
düşünün
o yüzden
std namespace'ni
kullanmayacağım
size tn
e
diyor ki
void pointer
türünden
char pointer
türüne
dönüşüm
herhangi bir şekilde
tanımsız
davranış
değil
char yıldız
p1
eşittir
c kodu
char yıldız
vp1
p2
eşittir
char yıldız
vp2
her kez dönen
bir döngü
oluşturuyorum
buradaki mantıkta
her yere
uymak zorunda
değil
yani
iki bellek
bloğunun
byte'larını
takas edersem
iki nesneyi
takas etmiş
olurum
tabi her türlü
hizmet vermez
bu anlamda
ama
çok güzel bir örnek
her kez dönen
bir döngü
oluşturuyorum
char temp
eşittir
yıldız p1
yıldız p2
eşittir
t
şimdi örneğin
iki tane
ilk nesneyi
takas etmek
istersem
bu fonksiyonu
nasıl
çağıracağım
g swap
address x
address y
size of
int
evet
eski
si
günlerimize
biraz geri döndürmek
için
bu tarzda
bir cinerek
fonksiyonu
daha yazalım
hadi bakalım
void
reverse
öyle bir fonksiyon ki
türden bağımsız
bir diziyi
reverse edecek
void yıldız
vp
tipik olarak
bu fonksiyonlar
bir parametresi
dizinin boyutunu
alıyor
bir parametresi
dizinin bir elemanına
size of'unu
alıyor
duruma göre
küre bağımlı işler içinde
bir
callback
function alıyor
arkadaşlar
reverse
algoritması
basit
değil mi
dizinin
boyutunun
yarısı kadar
dönen
bir döngü
oluşturmamız
gerekiyor
for
size t
i eşittir
sıfır
i küçük
size bölü
iki
artı artı
i
aslında türelimizde
olsaydı
sembolik olarak
yazıyorum
dizinin
i indisli
elemanıyla
dizinin
size
eksi
bir
i
indisli
elemanını
takas
etmem
gerekir
fakat
bunların
türünü
bilmiyorum
fakat
pointer
aritmetiyle
bunların
türünü
adresini
elde
edebilirim
çar
yıldız
p
eşittir
çar
yıldız
arada
c kodu
yazınca
kendimi iyi
hissedim
vp
şimdi
yukarıda
zaten
jenerik
swap
fonksiyonumuz
var
g swap
swap
edilecek
nesnelerden
birinin
adresi
pointer
aritmetiği
olsaydı
p artı
i
olacaktı
ama
şimdi
çarp pointer
aritmetiğine
göre
p artı
i
çarpı
s z
diğeri de
p artı
size
eksi
bir
i
çarpı
s z
ve boyutu
da
s z
işte bakın
isterseniz
deneyin
mis gibi bir
cennilik
reverse
fonksiyonu
amaçım
tabi
c
anlatmak
değil
fakat
bu şekilde
cenerik
kodlar
bir
runtime'a yönelik
iki
belirli
sınırları
var
yani
mesela
burada
biz
nesnelerin
swap
fonksiyonunun
nesnelerin
bellek bloklarındaki
byte'ları
swap
ettiğinde
nesnelerin de
değersel olarak
swap
edildiğini
varsayıyoruz
oysa bu
bir yapı
türüyle
kullanıldığında
içinde
pointer'lar
olabilir
vesaire
bir sürü
engel
oluşturabilir
ve birçok
durumda da
callback
fonksiyon
gerekiyor
değil mi
mesela
q sortta
olduğu gibi
b searchta
ama
sonuçta
jenerik
programlama
derken
bunları da
içine
almak
gerekiyor
çünkü
öyle ya da
böyle
bu fonksiyon
türden
bağımsız
olarak
hizmet
veriyor
aslında
arkadaşlar
kalıtımda
inheritance'da
jenerik
programlama
tarafında
başlı başına
bir araç
öyle değil mi
siz
bir fonksiyonun
parametresini
tavan sınıf
türünden
pointer ya da
referans
yaparsanız
o sınıf
hiyerarşisi
içinde
bütün
farklı
sınıflar
türünden
nesneleri
kabul edecek
sonuçta
bu da
jenerik bir yapı
öyle değil mi
hatta
c şart
java gibi
dillerde
bütün
sınıfların
kalıtımda
taban sınıfı
olan
orada
objekt
cisimli
sınıf var
orada zaten
böyle bir
sınırlama da
yok
her şey
bir
objekt
fakat
c++
en kuvvetli
olduğu yer
c++'ın
en kuvvetli
olduğu
yön
diyelim
jenerik
programlama
bu araçların
hepsi
void pointer
dahil
tabi ki
c++'da da
kullanılabilir
fakat
c++'daki
jeneriklik
derleyicinin
compile time'da
kod yazması
ile oluşturulan
jeneriklik
yani
c derleyicisinden
farklı olarak
c++
derleyicisi
bizim için
derleme zamanında
belirli tür
ya da türlere
yönelik
kod yazabiliyor
c++'da
jenerik
programlama
derken
eğer
aksi söylenmedikçe
kast edilen
her zaman
bu
derleyiciye
compile time'da
kod yazdırmak
bu açıdan
baktığımız zaman
c++
kodlarını
iki kategoriye
ayırabiliriz
biri
doğrudan
derleyicinin
derlediği
kod
şimdiye kadar
hep örnekler
böyleydi
bir de
varlık
nedeni
derleyiciye
kod yazdırmak
olan kod
öyle bir
kod formu
var ki
o kod formu
derleyiciye
kod yazdırma
hedefini
amacını
taşıyor
derleyici o
kod formundan
hareketle
bizim için
ayrı ayrı
türlere
ya da
sabitlere
yönelik
farklı kodlar
yazabiliyor
yani bütün
yapı
derleyicinin
compile time'da
derleme zamanında
kod
yazmasına
dayalı
ister buna
meta kod
deyin
ister c++'ın
terminolojisinde
kullanılan
template sözcüğünü
kullanın
c++'da
template dediğimiz
araç
derleyiciye
kod yazdırmanın
aracı
ve
maalesef
burada üzücü
bir haber
c++
sentaksının
en çetrefilli
olduğu
en karmaşık
en fazla
kural barındırdığı
alanda
burası
yani
c++'daki
jenerik
programlama
adeta
ayrı bir programlama
diliydi
yani
c++'ın
içinde
adeta
gömülü
ayrı bir
programlama
dilini
öğreneceğiz
bu programlama
dili
benim yakıştırmam
bu
derleyiciye
compile time'da
kod yazdırmaya
yönelik
değil
bu dilin
ayrı
kuralları var
çok sayıda
kuralı var
genel olarak
bu konuya
lütfen arkadaşlar
tmp
de deniyor
template
meta
programming
ve
her c++
standardıyla
bu tmp
tarafına
yeni araçlar
eklendiği için
ve
her c++
standardıyla
daha önceki
c++
standardında
olan
template'lere
ilişkin
kısıtlamalar
restriction'lar
kaldırıldığı
için
buradaki
araçlar
çok fazlalaştı
öğrenmemiz gereken
çok fazla
ve var
yani ben
şöyle desem
abartmış olmam
c++'da bu
tmp tarafını
öğrenmek
birçok programlama
dilinin kendisini
öğrenmekten
daha fazla
zaman alıyor
ve var
daha fazla
araç var
terkliğe
kod yazdıran
koddan
faydalanıyoruz
arkadaşlar
standart kütüphanemizin
en önemli
birleşe ne
STL diye
anılıyor
bu bir akronim
hepinizin bildiği gibi
standard
template
library
kronolojik olarak
bakarsak
STL
standart
kütüphanenin
kendisi
değil
standart
kütüphanenin
bir birleşeni
adı üstünde
jenerik
programlama
komponentlerinden
oluşan
o yüzden
standard
template
library
deniyor
bir
standart
kütüphanenin
birleşeni
ama
standart
kütüphanenin
çok
büyük
çoğunluğu
böyle
o yüzden
belki
%100
doğru
olmasa da
programcılar
STL'i
standart
kütüphane
anlamında
da kullanıyorlar
yani bu
aslında
teknik olarak
doğru değil
STL
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesinin
ismi mi
hayır
STL olmadan
önce de
C++'ın
bir standart
kütüphanesi
var mıydı
evet
ben o dönemde de
C++'da
kod yazıyordum
yani
STL daha sonradan
eklenen
bir kütüphane
ama şimdi
kütüphanemizin
standart
çok
büyük
çoğunluğunu
STL
oluşturduğu
için
arkadaşlar
artık
ben de
bazen
teknik olarak
doğru olmasa da
STL'i
standart
C++
library
anlamında da
kullanıyorum
ama dediğim gibi
teknik olarak
%100 doğru
değil
bizim de
gidişatımız
şöyle olacak
önce
jenerik programlama
paradigmasındaki
araçları
belirli bir
detay seviyesinde
bu çok önemli
bence bu
tanımlama
öğreneceğiz
neden belirli bir
detay seviyesinde
diyorum
arkadaşlar
abartmıyorum
bakın
sadece
template'lere ilişkin
ayrı bir kurs
olsaydı
bu konuya
meraklı kişilerin
katılacağı
o kursun
süresi
100 saat
200 saat
bile olabilirdi
o kadar geniş
bir konu
ama her zaman
olduğu gibi
belirli bir detay
seviyesinde
durmak zorundayız
ama ben
mümkün olduğu
kadar
üretimde
çalışacak bir
C++
programcısının
gerektiğinde
jenerik
komponentleri de
kendisi
yazabilecek
bir programcının
bilmesi gereken
her şeyi
bu bölümde
anlatmaya çalışacağım
zaten bu bölüm
bittikten sonra
standart
template
kütüphanesini
STL'i öğrenmeye
başlayacağız
ki eğer
template'leri
bilmezsek
ki birçok kişinin
eksiği burada
template konusunu
iyi anlamadıkları için
standart
kütüphaneyi de
ezbere
kullanıyorlar
bazı şeylerin
nasıl olduğunu
bilmeden
kullanıyorlar
o da
hata yapmayı
kaçınılmaz
hale getiriyor
o zaman önce
biz
template'leri
öğreneceğiz
arkadaşlar
C++
standartının
buraya dikkat
her
standartın
majör standartların
böyle önemli
birkaç tane
öğesi oluyor
belki
onlarca
araç
ekliyor
ama
her
eklenen
yeni
aracın
ya da
dil öğesinin
önemi
aynı
değil
mesela
C++
dediğiniz zaman
hemen
kime
sorsanız
der ki
aslında
böyle belki
yüz küsür
ekleme var
dile
ya da yapılan
değişiklik var
ya da
kısıtlamaların
kaldırılması var
ama
C++
standartı
deseniz
ki
aramızda
C++
kullananlar var
herkes der ki
konseptler
efendim
ranges
kütüphanesi
yani birkaç tane
önemli
temel
öğeden bahseder
ya da
korotinler
gibi
arkadaşlar
işte buradaki
C++
20'nin
majör
eklediği
araçlardan
bir tanesi
tamamen
jenerik programlama
paradigmasıyla
ilişkin
konseptler
yani aslında
konseptin kendisi de
bir
template
arkadaşlar
C++
sadece
standart
kütüphanesi
değil
üçüncü
parti
kütüphanelerden
de
en çok
kullanılan
kütüphaneler
örneğin
Boost
kütüphanesi
ağırlıkta
yine
jenerik
komponentlerden
oluşuyor
yani
templateleri
öğrenmek
jenerik
programlama
araçlarını
öğrenmek
sadece
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesinin
birleşeni
olan
STL'i
iyi öğrenmek
iyi kullanmak
için
gerekli
olmakta
kalmayıp
üçüncü
parti
kütüphaneler
içinde
gerekiyor
işte
en tipik
örneği
Boost'taki
komponentler
o zaman
biz de bir
giriş yapalım
arkadaşlar
önce şunu
söyleyerek
başlayalım
burada
template
sözcüğü
diye de
okuyorlar
template
diye de
telaffuz ediliyor
ben template
diye telaffuz
edeceğim
template
az önce
söylediğim gibi
derleyicinin
kod yazmasını
sağlayan
bir
kod formu
başka
programlama
ortamlarında
ya da
utility
programları
mesela
efendim
Microsoft
Word'ü
kullanıyorsunuz
orada da
template var
template'in
oradaki
anlamından
tamamen
bağımsız
daha önce
bu konuyla
tanışmamış
arkadaşlar
template
dediğimde
daha önce
template
teriminin
kullanıldığı
başka
domenlere
benzetmeye
çalışmasınlar
template'in
ne olduğunu
baştan
söyledim
template
derleyiciye
kod yazdıran
bir
kod formu
template'lerin
belirli
kategorileri
var
bir
function
template
dediğimizde
adı üstünde
amacı
derleyiciye
fonksiyon
kodu
yazdırmak
olan
kod
yani
bir
function
template
kullanılarak
derleyiciye
bir
fonksiyonun
kodu
yazdırılabilir
fonksiyon
kodu
yazdırmak
için
oluşturulan
template'lere
function
template
deniyor
class
template
adı üstünde
derleyiciye
sınıf
kodu
yazdıran
template'ler
yani bir
class template'ten
faydalanarak
arkadaşlar
derleyiciye
bir sınıf
kodu
yazdırabiliyoruz
variable
template
bu arada
function
template ve
class template
modern
C++
dan önce
de vardı
ama
variable
template
C++
standartıyla
eklendi
arkadaşlar
bu da
derleyiciye
bir değişken
tanımı
yaptıran
template
alias
type
anlamında
türeş
ismi
bu da
derleyiciye
bir türeş
ismi
bildirimi
yaptıran
template
ve nihayet
C++
ile
dile
eklenen
konseptler
var
bir konseptin
kendisi de
arkadaşlar
aynı zamanda
bir
template
arkadaşlar
derleyicinin
compile time'da
bir
template'ten
ister
function
template
ister
class
template
ister
variable
template
konsept
alias
template
olsun
derleyicinin
bir template'ten
faydalanarak
compile time'da
oluşturduğu
varlığın
kendisine
o template'in
bir
specialization'ı
deniyor
örneğin
func
bir fonksiyon
şablon
bu arada ben
Türkçe
template anlamında
şablon
terimini
kullanacağım
o da
Türkçe
değil
ama
olsun
o zaman
bir fonksiyon
şablonundan
elde edilen
ürünün
kendisi
yani
oluşan
fonksiyon
o fonksiyon
şablonunun
bir nesi
specialization'ı
ve ben
specialization
anlamında
Türkçe'de
sürekli
onu
İngilizce
terimi
terafız etmek
zorunda
kalmayalım
diye
açılım
terimini
kullanıyorum
o zaman
function
template'in
bir
specialization'ı
function'ın
kendisi
class template'in
bir specialization'ı
bir class'ın
kendisi
variable
template'in
bir specialization'ı
bir
variable'ın
kendisi
alias template'in
bir specialization'ı
bir
type
alias
declaration'ın
kendisi
buraya kadar
sormak istediğiniz
bir soru var mı
o zaman
biz
yavaş yavaş
function template'ler
class template
variable template
alias template
bunları
yavaş yavaş
belirli bir sırayla
öğreneceğiz
arkadaşlar
konsept hariç
bu template'lerin
hepsinde
konseptleri
ayrı
almak gerekiyor
template
oluşturmak
için
template
anahtar sözcüğünü
kullanıyoruz
bu arada
bu da
bu zorunluluk
da
C++20'yle
ortadan kalktı
template
anahtar sözcüğünden
sonra
bir
açısal parantez
angular bracket
yer alıyor
bu
angular
bracket
içinde
açısal parantez
diyorum ben
Türkçe
anlatılan
isimlere
arkadaşlar
o template'in
parametreleri
deniyor
template
parameters
lütfen
fonksiyon
parametreleriyle
karıştırmayın
açısal parantez
içinde
bildirimi
yapılan
öğelere
template'in
parametreleri
deniyor
ve çok
önemli bir
konu
arkadaşlar
template
parametreleri
farklı kategoride
olabiliyor
3 tane
temel
kategori
var
özellikle
ilk ikisi
bizi
yakından
ilgilendirecek
biri
şimdi neleri
yazıyoruz
template'in
parametre
kategorilerini
İngilizce'de
type
parameter
denilen
parametre
kategorisi
type
parametre
Türkçe
okuyorum
adı üstünde
bir
türe
karşılık
geliyor
yani
derleyici
template'imizden
faydalanarak
bir
specialization
oluşturduğunda
type
parametre
yerine
bir
type
kullanıyor
örneğin
int gibi
double
gibi
string
char
gibi
yani
template
parametresi
bir tür
olmak üzere
anlamında
ikinci kategori
arkadaşlar
non-type
parametre
deniyor
her ne kadar
non-type
parametre
dense de
belki
constant
parametre
dense de
biraz daha
yakışabilirdi
non-type
parametre
adı üstünde
tür
olmayan
bir
parametre
yani
örneğin
bir
sabit
ya da
belirli
türden
bir
değer
gibi
yani
kendisi
bir tür
değil
ama
bir türden
bir
değere
karşılık
geliyor
ve
üçüncü
kategoride
parametrenin
template
parametresinin
kendisinin
template
olması
ona da
template
parameter
deniyor
üçüncüsü
biraz
uzmanlık
konusu
ileri
C++
kursunda
daha çok
beğeneceğim
burada da
en azından
ilerleyen
zamanlarda
ne
olduğundan
işe
yarayabileceğinden
bahsedeceğiz
bizi daha
çok ilgilendiren
type
parametre
ve
non-type
parametre
arkadaşlar
template
anahtar
sözcüğünden
sonra
acısal
parantez
içinde
class
anahtar
sözcüğünü
ya da
type
name
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanarak
template
parametresi
oluşturuyorsunuz
C++'ın
ilk dönemlerinde
burada
sadece
class
anahtar
sözcüğü
kullanıyordu
halen de
class
anahtar
sözcüğünün
kullanımında
herhangi bir şekilde
bir engel yok
bu şu
demek
eğer bir isim
verirseniz
T
bir tür
olmak üzere
T
yize
type
yani
derleyici
bu
templateten
bir
specialization
oluşturduğunda
işte ona da
instantiation
deniyor
templatein
instantiate
edilmesi
deniyor
hepsine
değineceğiz
T'nin yerine
kendi yazdığı
kodda
bir tür
kullanacak
bir type
başlangıçta
sadece
class
anahtar
sözcüğü
vardı
başlangıçta
derken
modern
C++'dan
bahsetmiyorum
fakat
C++'ın
daha sonraki
dönemlerinde
modern C++'dan
çok daha
öncesinden
bahsediyorum
type
name
anahtar
sözcüğü
de
eklendi
yani
günümüzün
kurallarında
template
tür
parametresi
için
class
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanmanızla
type
name
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanmanız
arasında
hiçbir
fark
yok
burada
bu
bağlamda
arkadaşlar
class
anahtar
sözcüğününün
belki bir
dezavantajı
şu
sanki
bu
template
parametresi
karşılığı
derleyicinin
kullanacağı türe
ona da
template
argument
deniyor
burada maalesef
birçok derimi
öğrenmek zorundayız
ve bunları
sık sık
tekrar edeceğim
template
argument
sanki
bir sınıf
türü
bir
class
type
olmaz
zorunluluğu
varmış
gibi bir
çağrışım
yaratıyor
özellikle yeni
öğrenenler
üstünde
oysa
derleyicinin
yazacağı
kodda
specialization
için
yazacağı
kodda
t karşılığı
kullanılan
template
argümanı
arkadaşlar
pekala
primitif
bir tür
olabilir
mesela t
için
int
kullanılabilir
mi
evet
int bir sınıf
mı
hayır
t için
double
kullanılabilir
mi
evet
o yüzden
hyphen
anahtar
sözcüğü
daha çok
tercih ediliyor
ama
class
anahtar
sözcüğünün
kullanımı
da tamamen
ortadan
kalkmış
diyemeyiz
mesela
cppreference.com
bakarsanız
orada
örneklerin
çoğunda
halen
template
parametreleri
için
class
anahtar
sözcüğünün
kullanıldığını
göreceksiniz
yalnız
bir şeye
dikkat
şimdiden
söyleyelim
type name
anahtar
sözcüğünün
kullanıldığı
bir bağlam
daha var
o bağlamdan
ileride
bahsedeceğim
o bağlamda
type name'in
yerine
class
kullanamıyorsunuz
yani sadece
açısal parantez
içinde
template
tür
parametresi
template
type
parametrin
bildirilmesinde
class
type name
aynı anlamda
type name'in
kullanıldığı
diğer bağlamlarda
class
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanma
şansım
yok
arkadaşlar
birden fazla
template
parametresi
olabilir
o zaman
comma separated
list
kullanıyoruz
ve farklı
bir isim
seçmemiz
gerekiyor
örneğin
type name
t
u
gibi
bu arada
tıpkı
fonksiyon
parametrelerinde
olduğu gibi
eğer
template
kod içinde
parametreleri
kullanmayacaksam
isim
vermek
zorunda
da değilim
burayı
anladık mı
mesela
diyelim ki
şöyle bir
bildirim yapacağım
bir sınıf
bildirimi
böyle yazsam
herhangi bir şekilde
bir sakıncası
yok
ama
template
tanımlarında
çoğunlukla
template
parametrelerini
kod içinde
kullandığımızdan
ki bazen
kullanmıyoruz
o zaman
onu kullanabilmek
için
bir isme
ihtiyacım
burada
tipik olarak
konvensiyonel
bazı isimler
kullanılıyor
mesela
t
u
v
w
gibi
isimler
çok yaygın
türler için
tercih edilen
isimler
ya da
bazı
özel
template
parametreleri
için
onların
hizmet ettiği
türlere
çağrışım
yapsın
diye
iter
gibi
fn
isimler
de
kullanıyoruz
şimdilik
onlara
değmeyeceğim
ben
sentaksı
anlattığım
örneklerde
nasıl
kalıtım
sentaksını
anlatırken
base
der gibi
isimler
kullanmışsam
burada da
belirli bir
bağlam
söz konusu
değilse
t
u
v
gibi
isimleri
kullanacağım
evet
arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
template
parametresi
kategorilerinden
herhangi birine
ilişkin olabilir
mesela bu
bir fonksiyon
şablonu da
olabilir
efendim bu
bir
sınıf
şablonu da
olabilir
ama ne olursa
olsun
ister
fonksiyon
şablonu
ister
sınıf
şablonu
ister
değişken
şablonu
burada
t
ne anlamda
demek
bir
tür
demek
yani derleyici
bu
şablondan
bir
kod
oluşturduğunda
t'nin yerine
bir tür
kullanacak
aslında biz
ezbere de
olsa
arkadaşlar
bunu kullandık
mesela
vektör
bir sınıf
şablonu
biz
vektörün
int açılımı
derken
aslında
vektör sınıf
şablonunun
birinci template
parametresi
karşılığı
derleyicinin
yazacağı
kodda
int türünün
kullanılmasını
istediğimizi
belirtmiş
oluyoruz
işte burada
template
parametresine
karşılık
derleyicinin
kullanacağı
türe
template
parametresi
type
parametre
ise
template
argümanı
ya da
template
type
argümanı
diyoruz
bu
birinci
kategori
ikinci
buna da
non-type
parametre
deniyordu
syntax
bu sefer
şöyle
non-type
parametre
bir değere
karşılık
geldiği
için
arkadaşlar
type
name
ya da
class
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanmak
yerine
bu
kullanılacak
değerin
türünü
yazıyorsunuz
örneğin
int
x
gibi
arkadaşlar
ne
template
olduğundan
bağımsız
bu
şu
demek
derleyici
bizim
için
bu
şablondan
templetten
bir
kod
ürettiğinde
template
non-type
parametresi
karşılığı
bu
türden
bir
değer
kullanacak
örneğin
ben
değerini
seçmişsem
sabitini
derleyicinin
yazdığı
sınıf
kodunda
benim
x'i
kullandığım
yerde
sabiti
kullanılacak
özellikle
bu
non-type
parametreler
söz konusu
olduğunda
c++
standardıyla
çok ciddi
bir devrim
yaşandı
eskiden
yani
c++
den
önce
non-type
parametrede
tam sayı
türleriyle
ya da
pointer
referans
türleriyle
bir
sınırlama
kısıtlama
vardı
mesela
gerçek sayı
türünü
kullanma imkanınız
yoktu
isterseniz
deneyin
c++
den
önce
böyle bir
template
oluşturduğunuzda
derleyici ise
doğrudan
sentax
hatası
verdi
fakat
c++
ile
buradaki
kısıtlamalar
aldırıldığı
gibi
daha önce
olmayan
yeni
non-type
parametre
araçları
da
eklendi
evet
o zaman
tekrar
edelim
type name
ya da
class
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanarak
template
tür
parametresi
oluşturuyorum
arkadaşlar
eğer ben
bir
değerin
derleyicinin
yazdığı
kodda
derleyici
tarafından
kullanılmasını
istiyorsam
o değerin
türünü
yazıyorum
yine
nasıl burada
bu parametreyi
kod içinde
kullanmayacaksam
isim vermek
mecbule
olmadığı
gibi
burada da
yine
bu değeri
kullanmayacaksam
salt
parametre
olarak
bulunmasını
istiyorsam
isim
vermeme
gerek yok
ama kod içinde
kullanıyorsam
isim
vereceğim
arkadaşlar
şimdi bunun
ne demek
olduğunu
kafanızda
canlandırmanızı
istiyorum
bu arada
şu sorunun
da hemen
cevabını
verelim
aynı
template içinde
hem type parametre
hem non type parametre
olabilir mi
olabilir
hatta o
üçüncü
bu kursun
kapsamında
çok az yer alan
template template
parametrede
olabilir mi
evet
yani tek bir
templatete
birden fazla
farklı template
parametresi
olabilir
mesela
arkadaşlar
bu templatein
birinci parametresi
template tür
parametresi
ikinci parametresi
template
non type parametre
hocam
burada
n
constant expression
olmak zorunda
mı
güzel bir
soru
n'in kendisi
bir ifade
değil
n bir isim
ama sorunuzu
şöyle alıyorum
oğuzhan
n'e karşılık
gelen argüman
sabit ifadesi
olmak zorunda
mı
değil mi
asıl sorulan
soru bu
çünkü
n bir ifade
cevap
evet
n'e karşılık
gelen ifade
bir sabit
ifadesi
olmak zorunda
ama onların
hepsini
ben şimdi kısa kısa
cevaplar veriyorum
alt başlıklar altında
teker teker
inceleyeceğiz
bu bölüm kursun
en uzun bölümlerinden
biri olacak
onu baştan
söyleyeyim
arkadaşlar
evet
kısa cevabım
template
non type tipi
değişerek
function overloading
yapılabilir mi
bu da
güzel bir soru
çok önemli bir soru
ama çok erken bir soru
bir kere
function overloadingden
bahsedebilmemiz için
templateimizin
function template
olması gerekiyor
deniz bu bir
o yüzden şimdi
benim anlattığım
kısım
bütün templateleri
ilgilendiriyor
sadece function
templateleri değil
ama yine sorunuza
şimdi çok kısa
bir cevap vereyim
a
fonksiyon şablonları
arkadaşlar
gerçek fonksiyonlarla
bir arada bulunabilir
yani
function overloading'e
iştirak eden
fonksiyonlardan biri
örneğin
bir fonksiyon şablonunun
specialization'ı
olabilir
ayrıca
fonksiyon şablonlarının
kendisi de
overload edilebilir
yani
aynı isimli
iki tane farklı
fonksiyon şablonu
olabilir mi
deniz
olabilir
yani
sizin sorduğunuz
sorunun cevabı da
evet aslında
ama
çok erken bir soru
erken olmasının dışında
çok da önemli bir soru
aynı zamanda
evet
o zaman biz
yavaş yavaş
ilerlememize devam edelim
type parametrelerimiz var
ve
non type parametrelerimiz var
non type parametreleri
ilişkin
kısıtlamalar
büyük ölçüde
C++ 20
standardıyla
kaldırıldı
arkadaşlar
template
type name
diyelim ki böyle bir
templateimiz olsun
ve bu bir fonksiyon şablonu olsun
void func
p
ister fonksiyon şablonu olsun
ister sınıf şablonu olsun
biz
template parametrelerini
kod içinde
istediğimiz gibi
belirli şartlara
uymak kaydıyla
kullanabiliyoruz
mesela
diyelim ki
böyle bir
fonksiyon şablonu olsa
çok dikkatli izleyelim
derleyicinin
bu fonksiyon şablonundan
bu function template'ten
bir specialization'ı
oluşturabilmesi için
T türünün yerine
hangi türün
kullanılması gerektiğini
bilmesi gerekiyor
yine aynı şekilde
eğer
non-type parametre varsa
non-type parametre
yerine de
hangi sabitin
ya da hangi değerin
kullanılması
gerektiğini
bilmesi gerekiyor
işte
template parametrelerine
karşılık
kullanılan
öelere
template argümanı
diyoruz
mesela
bu template'ten
derleyicinin
bir fonksiyon
kodu oluşturması
durumunda
derleyici
T türünün
int olması
gerektiğini
öğrenirse
o zaman
geri dönüş
değeri
int olan
ismi
bank olan
parametresi
int olan
bir fonksiyon
oluşturacak
fonksiyonun
parametrelerinin
türünde
geri dönüş
değeri
türünde
ya da fonksiyonun
kodunu görüyorsa
derleyici
fonksiyonun
kodunda
T türünü
kullanabiliriz
ama sadece
T olarak
değil
mesela
aman buraya
dikkat
diyelim ki
fonksiyon
şöyle olsaydı
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonun
kodundan
bir örnek verelim
fonksiyon
şöyle olsaydı
derleyici
T türünün
ne olduğunu
öğrendiğinde
diyelim ki
derleyici
compile time'da
T türünün
yerine
int türünün
kullanılacağını
anladı
o zaman
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
int
parametresi
pointer to
int
12.
satırda
yapılan
bildirimde
r
değişkeninin
türü
int
ref olacak
ya da
örneğin
burada
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
non type
parametre
olsaydı
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
şöyle bir
izi
tanımlanmış
olsaydı
derleyici
compile time'da
T yerine
int
n yerine
kullanılacağını
öğrendiğinde
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
kodda
12.
satırdaki
dizi
20 elemanlı
bir int
dizi
olacaktı
oysa derleyici
bu fonksiyon
şablonundan
bu kez
başka bir
fonksiyon
kodu
oluşturduğunda
bu seferde
T'nin
double
int
n'in
karşılığı
da
değerinin
kullanılacağını
öğrendiğinde
bu
double türden
10 elemanlı
bir dizi
olacaktı
soru
T yerine
incomplete
type
kullanabilir miyiz
belirli
bağlamlarda
yani
şöyle
söylersem
evet her zaman
kullanabilirsiniz
dersem
o doğru
olmaz
belirli bağlamlarda
kullanabiliriz
deniz
kullanamayız
şimdilik ben sadece
template parametresini
ne demek
template argümanını
önce
onlardan
bahsediyormuş
şimdi burada
çok önemli
bir soru
aslında şu
madem
derleyici
bir
template
koddan
bir
specialization
oluştururken
template'in
parametreleri
karşılığı
kullanılan
template argümanlarını
bilmek
zorunda
peki
nasıl
bilecek
derleyici
template
parametreleri
için
kullanılan
argümanların
neler
olacağını
nasıl
bilecek
arkadaşlar
bunu
bilmesinin
de
konu
sinir bozucu
şekilde
yeni öğrenen
arkadaşlar için
başlangıçta
karmaşık
ve geniş
olabilir
ne yapalım
benim kusurum
değil
katlanacaksınız
ama hepsini
öğrenmek
zorundayız
bunun içinde
farklı farklı
araçlar var
araçlardan biri
deduction
yani
derleyici
koda
bakarak
siz
template
parametresi
karşılığı
hangi
argümanın
kullanılacağını
söylemeseniz de
koda
bakarak
derleyici
bunun
çıkarımını
yapabiliyor
yani
ingilizce
fiiliyle
deduce
edebiliyor
deduction
yapabiliyor
bu çok sık
kullanılan bir
mekanizma
ayrıntılı
göreceğiz
mesela
fonksiyon
şablonlarında
uzun uzun
şimdi anlatmayacağım
ama
genel
makro düzeyde
bakıyoruz
diyelim ki
bu şekilde
bildirilmiş bir
fonksiyon
şablonu
olsun
siz bu
fonksiyona
bir argüman
gönderdiğinizde
beynali
kurallar
dahilinde
o kuralları
hızlı bir şekilde
öğreneceğiz
bundan sonraki
derslerde
terleyici
örneğin
bu basit
örnek için
fonksiyona
gönderilen
argüman
olan ifadenin
türünün
int olduğundan
hareketle
template
parametresi
karşılığı
kullanılacak
template
argümanının
int türü
olması
gerektiğini
anlayacak
sırf bu
konu bile
bizim
bir buçuk
iki saatimiz
olacak
ya da şöyle bir
template olduğunu
düşünün
arkadaşlar
ve bu
fonksiyonun
parametresinin
örneğin
şöyle
bildirildiğini
düşünün
siz şimdi
ya da şöyle
yazalım
ben yazacaktım
mesela
diyelim ki
böyle bir
diziniz var
int
a
bu fonksiyonu
dizisini
argüman
olarak
kullanıp
çağırdığınızda
dilin
bundan sonra
öğreneceğimiz
kurallarına
göre
derleyici
t türü
karşılığı
int
tür
argümanının
n
non
type
parametre
karşılığı
da
değerinin
kullanılacağını
anlayacak
burada
gördüğünüz
gibi
ben
fang
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yaptığımda
derleyiciye
şunu açıkça
söylemedim
değil mi
derleyici
fang template'inden
bana öyle bir
fonksiyon kodu
yaz ki
t türü
int olsun
en sabiti de
40 olsun
demedim
ama
derleyici koda
bakarak
bunun
çıkarımını
yaptı
yani burada
çok
detaylı
öğrenmemiz
gereken
bir
deduction
mekanizması
var
ama
deduction
tek yol
değil
ikinci yol
template
parametreleri
karşılığı
kullanılacak
template
targümanlarının
eksplisit
olarak
derleyiciye
bildirilmesi
yani
yine
belirli bir
sentaksla
diyeceğiz ki
derleyici
ben senin
çıkarım
yapmanı
istemiyorum
template
parametreleri
karşılığı
şu
türü
ya da
şu
değeri
ya da
şu türleri
şu değeri
kullanabilirsin
diyeceğim
örneğin
yukarıdaki
fonksiyonu
pekala
şöyle de
çağırabilirdim
şimdilik
sentaksı
aklınızda
tutmayın
int
virgül
yirmi
bize kalsın
şöyle de
çağırabilirdim
int
virgül
yirmi
işte
burada
kullanılan
arkadaşlar
sentaksa
eksplisit
template
argümanları
deniyor
açısal
parantez içinde
template
parametrelerine
karşılık
gelen
argümanları
yazıyorsunuz
her birini
ayrıntılı olarak
önümüzdeki derslerde
göreceğiz
şimdi
makro
düzeyde
genel
kategorileri
öğreniyoruz
demek ki
bir
deduction
mekanizması var
bir de
template
argümanlarına
karşılık gelen
arkadaşlar
argümanların
eksplisit
olarak
derleyiciye
yazılması var
deduction
yapma
ben bu
türü
kullanmak
istiyorum
mesela
tahmin
ettiğiniz
gibi
az önceki
örnekte
ya da
şimdiye
kadar
yazdığımız
bazı
örneklerde
biz
vektör
sözcüğünden
sonra
açısal parantez
içine
int
yazdığımızda
aslında
vektör
sınıf
şablonunun
birinci
template
parametresi
karşılığı
kullanılması
gereken
tür
argümanının
int
olduğunu
eksplisit
olarak
bildirmiş
oluyoruz
modern
C++'da
özellikle
C++ 17
standartıyla
bu konuda
şöyle bir
devrimsel
değişiklik
de oldu
C++ 17
standartından
önce
deduction
mekanizması
sadece
fonksiyon
şablonları
için
söz konusuydu
yani
sınıf
şablonları
için
deduction
söz
konusu
değildi
C++ 17
standardıyla
bence
yapılan
en önemli
eklemelerden
biri
bu terimi
duymuş
olmalısınız
ya da
duymamışsınız
bundan sonra
çok duyacaksınız
benden
CITAT
diye
kısaltılıyor
böyle bir
akronim var
aslında
açılımı
class
template
argument
deduction
belirli
sınırlar
dahilinde
sınıf
şablonlarında
da
template
parametrelerine
karşılık
gelen
template
argümanlarının
çıkarımı
yapılması
olanağa
kazandırıldı
evet
bahset
bugünkü dersinizde
bir giriş bile
yapamadık
ama
çarşamba
günü
epey
ilerleyeceğiz
arkadaşlar
bu template
konusu o kadar
geniş ki
bir iki
dersi
kaçırırsanız
ondan sonra
canlı derslere
katıldığınız zaman
hiçbir şey
anlamıyor
durumuna düşebilirsiniz
o yüzden
bir dahaki
dersler
özellikle
kayıttan
izleyen
arkadaşlar
bundan sonraki
derse
örneğin
canlı katılımı
sağlayacaklarsa
mutlaka
bugünkü
dersi
izlemiş
olmaları
gerekiyor
template
konusunda
her ders
için
böyle
çünkü
öğrendiğimiz
araçları
daha sonraki
derslerde
biliniyor
farz ederek
kullanmaya
başlayacağız
ben
Necat Ergin
derse
katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
gnej nedir
dost
heading